bien
mesdames messieurs chers collègues
je vous remercie de rejoindre vos places
nous accueillons cette après midi
monsieur mise à l'intérieur et madame la
ministre
mancha pas pour une audition consacrée à
la préparation aux travaux relatifs aux
textes confortant les valeurs de la
république
je crois que le plus simple
enfin je rappelle à tout le monde mais
chacun le sait que la commission des
lois examinera le rapport de nos deux
co-rapporteurs madame veria et madame
eustache brinio le mercredi 17 mars
prochain et que le texte viendra ensuite
la date bêtise je sais plus si c'est le
30 ou le 1er avril
c'est pas le premier le 30 mars en
séance
c'est le ministre madame le ministre je
crois que je vous laisse la parole c'est
le plus simple
je pense que c'est vous peut-être que
j'ai mes disques débuter ou madame
mettez vous d'accord
on est d'accord j'imagine que vous
l'êtes merci monsieur le président
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les dessinateurs avec magna
pas nous sommes évidemment très honorés
d'être invités devant votre commission
pour évoquer un texte important un texte
important évidemment pour la pour la
législature un texte important pour le
pays et un texte important parce que
c'est un travail considérable que de
toucher un certain nombre de grandes
libertés parfois chèrement acquise très
encadrés par le droit conventionnel le
droit constitutionnel notre droit
positif la liberté d'association la
liberté de culte la liberté d'expression
la laïcité est en même temps doit un
équilibre avec les attaques que subit la
france depuis de nombreuses années
désormais première vague
terroristes islamistes 95 pas très loin
d'ici
la fnac et saint michel puis 2001 qui
évidemment a marqué un
l'internationalisation des attaques
terroristes
et puis évidemment nous avons tous connu
les attentes a projeté de 2015 2016 est
désormais ce que gilles kepel appel à
janis mme d'atmosphère quelque chose
peut-être de plus de plus confus mais
tout aussi réel et de tout aussi
meurtriers mais ce texte de loi ne vise
pas à lutter une énième fois contre le
terrorisme beaucoup de gouvernements se
sont armés et ont armé la france tant
par des moyens supplémentaires que par
des dispositions législatives
supplémentaires mais entre le terrorisme
entre la radicalisation qui mène au
terrorisme et y rien il ya quelque chose
que le président n'a vu qu'à lui-même
qualifié de séparatisme cet islam
politique
cet islam radical qui est une dérive
sectaire d'une religion que nous ne
confondons en aucun cas avec une
religion elle n'est pas considérée
aujourd'hui comme étant la conséquence
de ce qui peut mener à ce dialy sme
d'atmosphère est ce que nous essayons de
faire c'est de limiter voire d'arrêter
dans certains cas de supprimer
l'entrisme du séparatisme en général est
évidemment le premier de ces séparatisme
le séparatisme islamistes même s'il
n'est pas le seul et que nous faisons la
loire je l'espère pour les années voire
pour les dizaines d'années qui viennent
afin de renforcer les principes
républicains qui permet de lutter contre
ce séparatisme dont on a vu dans la cas
de monsieur samuel pâtit que à la fois
l'entrisme dans les services publics pop
locaux le communautarisme et freiner la
pression sur les agents publics comme la
diffusion par les réseaux sociaux d'une
sorte de fatwa de fatwas numérique qui
arment intellectuellement le terroriste
se ce lien entre le séparatisme l'islam
politique et le terrorisme existe et
nous le savions confusément mais nous
savons désormais qu'il n'ya pas de
différence de nature mais une différence
de degré et celui ci que nous devons
combattre alors les dispositions de ce
texte
sont nombreuses et elle concerne tous
les champs dont nous pensons qu'ils sont
des chants qui sont ceux désormais de
l'expansion du séparatisme islamistes
d'abord en premier lieu les services
publics et singulièrement les services
publics locaux pendant longtemps ou le
savez mieux que personne vous êtes des
élus représentant les territoires nous
avons délégué le service public
alors c'est bien ou est-ce que c'est pas
bien c'est une autre question en tout
cas le fait est que les transports les
lieux
évidemment a connu dit qu un certain
nombre de dispositions de la vie de tous
les jours sont transférés au privé et
des centaines de milliers d'agents
aujourd'hui font le travail du service
public sans avoir obligatoirement les
obligations des agents du service public
c'est à dire la neutralité neutralité
politique et une neutralité évidemment
religieux et l'article 1er vous le savez
de ce texte de loi est très important
puisqu'il va étendre la neutralité
religieuse et politique a des centaines
de milliers de salariés qui ont un
travail qui s'assimile à ceux de la
fonction publique ils vont imposer dans
les transports en commun dans l'est dans
les lieux délégation service public
cette neutralité
le nonce port du voile par exemple
puisque c'est le cas évidemment que que
qui est le plus le plus reconnu mais
aussi les arrangements autour des
horaires ou les lieux de prière qui
peuvent exister dans certains endroits
qui sont déléguer au privé
il y à des dispositions qui concerne
toujours les collectivités locales
notamment un article très important dont
nous avons fait le compromis évoqué par
le conseil d'état en lien je voudrais le
dire avec le président de l'association
des maires de france qui est notamment
le référé laïcité pour intervenir
lorsque des actes sont pris par des
collectivités locales et son contraire
au principe de laïcité
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler se
référer aux laïcité est évidemment sous
le contrôle absolu du juge administratif
et respecte bien sûr article 72 delà de
la constitution indépendamment je vais
pas tous ces détails et de ces mesures
qui concernent les collectivités locales
il ya des mesures qui concerne le champ
associatif
on sait tous que la richesse du monde
associatif dans notre pays est très
importante elle contribuer à la
nécessaire solidarité à la citoyenneté à
la vie de chacune et de chacun mais
c'est aussi parfois malheureusement trop
souvent constatés d
d'entrisme de ce séparatisme en triste
d'autant plus scandaleuse lorsqu'il agit
parce que cette subversion agissent ou
subventions notamment subventions
publiques
qu'il s'agisse des collectivités locales
des organismes qu'on pourrait qualifier
de la sphère étatique ou locales en tout
cas public et de l'état et donc je ne
détaillerai pas davantage ce point parce
que madame amis délégués évoquera
notamment ces questions autour du monde
associatif et du contrat d'engagement
mais je veux aussi souligner le fait que
nous renforçons les dispositions qui
permettent de suspendre nouveautés ou de
dissoudre les associations qui resteront
toujours suspendues ou dissoutes en
conseil des ministres comme je lé fais
ce matin pour une association dans la
presse relève l'action mais évidemment
permet david intervenir de manière plus
forte pour que les ennemis de la
république ne puisse pas existé sur
notre sol façon structurée et sans
contestation
le troisième point c'est évidemment là
la haine et notamment la haine en ligne
la radicalisation sur internet et
parfois bien plus efficace qu ailleurs
plus efficace parfois dans des lieux de
culte et donc le ministre de la justice
est le seul être d'état numérique aura
sans doute l'occasion dans l'hémicycle
monsieur le président ou devant votre
commission est évidemment de pouvoir
dire à quel point les dispositions
nouvelles notamment ce qu'on appelle les
sites miroirs qui est un point
extrêmement important que porte ce texte
de loi est en avance de ce que fait la
commission européenne puisque nous avons
travaillé avec le commissaire thierry
breton si j'ose dire en même temps pour
que les dispositions luttant contre la
haine en ligne puisse puisse être prise
dans ce texte de loi
quatrième sujet après les services
publics locaux étatique
après le monde associatif après la haine
en ligne il s'agit évidemment de lutter
contre les pressions qui sont faites
contre les agents publics il ya
notamment deux articles extrêmement
important celui qui relève du délit de
séparatisme et de toute personne qui vit
répression son service public sur ces
agents pourraient être condamnés par ce
délit nouveau de 5 ans et dont le juge
pourra prononcer l'exécutent de
l'exécution de la peine
en même temps qu'une
le cul tf pour quitter le territoire
national lorsqu'il s'agit d'un étranger
mais aussi de l'article 18 dont
j'imagine votre commission va largement
par les dix articles samuel pâtit chacun
a suivi cela et puis dernier point ce
que je voudrais insister et qui est tout
sauf anodin et qui prendra sans doute
beaucoup de temps je sais dans cette
chambre du sénat le président larcher je
sais y est très attaché vous même
monsieur le président et chacune et
chacun ici c'est le renforcement des
dispositions cultuelle qui sont très
importantes à la fois dans l'aide que
nous apportons au culte c'est notamment
le cas de simplification venant de la
loi de 1905
c'est notamment le cas évidemment
d'ouverture des immeubles de rapport qui
nous occupera j'imagine un certain temps
et que tu es un sujet extrêmement
important et de l'autre côté le
renforcement également de la laïcité
telle que aristide briand et gustave
dron je voudrais citer ici gustave dron
sénateur maire de tourcoing qui est
porta au sénat la part sénatoriale de la
loi de séparation des églises et de
l'état en renforçant 1905 et en
obligeant le plus possible on aura
l'occasion de reparler de ces
dispositions que les cultes puisse
organiser selon un dispositif qui a été
inventé pour eux qui s'appelle la loi
1905 et des contraintes que nous devons
assumer notamment le fait qu'aujourd'hui
le miz intérieure ne connaît pas et ne
peut pas répondre aux parlementaires
lorsqu'il interroge lors des
financements étrangers on ne connaît pas
ces financements étrangers sur le sol
national et un port n'ont pas s'y
opposer
donc des dispositions aussi intéressante
que celle ci avec des amendements
parlementaires qui ont été adoptée après
avis du gouvernement notamment
d'interdiction de vente de lieux de
culte sans l'accord de l'état à d'autres
états étrangers c'est un point
évidemment extrêmement important et
j'allais signer tout à fait l'article
qui nous permet de fermer les deux
cultes lorsqu'ils sont soupçonnés de
séparatisme et sur ce point je voudrais
m'arrêter quelques instants puisque j'ai
de nombreuses questions de
parlementaires sur le fait qu' on évalue
aujourd'hui à peu près 80 90 89 dit
exactement les rangs seulement
territoriaux des lieux de culte 10
séparatiste il ya 2500 ans le culte
musulman en france dont convient que 89
sur 2500 ce n'est pas une proportion
importante mais évidemment
ces 89 pose des questions très important
pour la paix publique pour l'ordre
public
et aujourd'hui la mise de numis de
l'intérieur ne peuvent faire fermer des
lieux de culte que ce deux angles le
premier c'est celui né de la loi sylt
c'est à dire en lien direct avec un
attentat terroriste
encore faut-il que cet attentat a eu
lieu puisqu'il s'agit évidemment pas de
pouvoir le faire fermer comme minority
report et de films prévoyait des
algorithmes de prédiction il faut
attendre que cet événement dramatique et
eu lieu il faut aussi de prouver le lien
et c'est évidemment le cadre de la
mosquée de pantin que j'ai fait fermer
vous l'avez constaté au lendemain d'un
assassinat de monsieur pâtit aujourd'hui
alors que nous connaissons évidemment
l'expansion islamistes dans le monde et
singulièrement dans notre pays il n'y a
qu'à ce lieu de culte qui est fermé au
nom de cette disposition et les autres
fermetures de gnôle cultes sont fermés
au titre des er paix comme n'importe
quel le rp de votre commune que dont
vous êtes élu et si jamais les contrôles
sont nombreux et gelé je le dis devant
vous pour la première fois si j'ose dire
ce nouveau chiffre 17 culte sur les 89
sont fermés au titre des rp mais ne le
sont pas au nom des discours qui porte
et un discours qui viendrait à dire que
les juifs les mécréants les catholiques
que les chrétiens tous ceux qui veulent
changer de religion les homosexuels sont
absolument évidemment à mettre à côté de
la société que les femmes sont
évidemment inférieurs aux sommes tous
les discours que vous pouvez dénoncer et
dont parfois vous m'écrivez pour me dire
mais que faites vous monsieur le
ministre la loi de la république ne me
permet pas de faire fermer ces lieux de
culte et des dispositions que nous vous
proposons permettent d' mainmise
l'intérieur de sa ferme et ses lieux de
culte et notamment évidemment lorsque le
juge administratif le confirmera comme
c'est souvent le cas
comme c'est quasiment toujours le cas
comme c'est toujours le cas d'ailleurs
depuis je suis mise à l'intérieur
puisque je voudrais saluer la justice
administrative qui accompagnent
évidemment les décisions administratives
dans leur proportionnalité et donc je
veux dire au sénat
indépendamment de nos sans doute nos
différences importantes il manque
vraiment des dispositions qui permettent
de faire la police de l'ordre public au
ministre de l'intérieur pour répondre
aux interrogations
rose que les représentants de la nation
pause promise l'intérieur et à la un
moment où la loi sera promulguée par le
président de la république monsieur
président et demandant avec madame la
ministre aux services du ministère de
l'intérieur de préparer en même temps
les décrets d'application nous nous
sommes tout à fait prêts évidemment à
partager la rédaction et la lecture en
séance
je ferai organisée par les services du
ministère de l'intérieur le contrôle au
nom de la loi nouvelle et des
dispositions corps a bien voulu doter le
parlement le ministère de l'intérieur
des 89 notre culte séparatistes dans les
semaines qui suivront
parce que s'il y en a qui sont
soupçonnés à tort elles doivent être
rangés dans la catégorie évidemment des
lieux de culte qui doivent tout à fait
pouvoir vivre leur religion comme ils
l'entendent
c'est une liberté tout à fait
fondamental est que nous devons
absolument respectés et dans l'autre
temps aucun français ne peut comprendre
que nous puissions dire qu'il ya 89
lutte séparatiste ne pas les faire
fermer se séparait de tel ou tel
responsable religieux ou de tel ou tel
responsable d'association cultuelle et
ce plan d'action qui est un plan de
réaction de la république vis-à-vis de
la paix publique vise à la fois bien sûr
à protéger l'intégralité de ce qu'ils
croient n'oublions pas que les musulmans
sont les premiers à être les victimes
dans le monde de la barbarie islamiste
on a vu ce que donnait ces islamistes ce
qu'ils étaient en responsabilité
politique et bien sûr de respecter les
règles de la république qui vise
évidemment à se protéger
dans ce contexte si dangereux que nous
connaissons voilà ce que je vis en
quelques mots monsieur le président on
les sent peut-être à la ministre le soin
de développer à la fois la question
associative je les dis mais aussi de
toutes les dispositions que j'ai pas
voulu évoquer puisqu'elle en est si
j'ose dire
la responsable est la créatrice qui sont
toutes les fonctions autour de l'état
civil
l'égalité entre femmes et même contre
les dérives sectaires si monsieur mehdi
mahdavikia parole merci monsieur le
président mes derniers à porter un média
mais sénatrice mais sur les sénateurs
avec le ministre de l'intérieur nous
avons effectivement présenté ce texte en
conseil des ministres le 9 décembre
dernier à l'occasion des cent quinze ans
de l'adoption de la loi de 1905
j'aimerais rappeler comme la féminité
qu'il est le fruit de larges
consultations qui ont été conduites avec
la société civile et partis politiques
les représentants des cultes des élus
des intellectuels des associations
philosophique il a été comme vous le
savez examiné par l'assemblée nationale
et discuter très largement notre
objectif il est clair il s'agit de
défendre nos valeurs la promesse
républicaine de la laïcité
d'émancipation de progrès et de lutter
contre le terreau du terrorisme est donc
très clairement pour rentrer dans le vif
des mesures que j'ai le plaisir de
porter auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
ça passe pour nous par un principe
simple et concret en terme financier
notre mot d'ordre c'est pas un euro
d'argent public qui ne doit être donnée
aux ennemis de la république en ce sens
et comme l'a souhaité le présent la
république et comme il l'a annoncé à
plusieurs reprises nous proposons dans
le cadre de cette fois la création d'un
contrat d'engagement républicain les
associations qui souhaitent recevoir une
subvention publique quelle qu'elle soit
qu'il s'agisse de subventions de l'état
en centrales ont déconcentré ou de la
part des collectivités s'engageront par
ce texte de contrat d'engagement
républicains à respecter les principes
les valeurs de la république en cas de
non respect la subvention sera arrêtée
et elle pourra être reprise ce qui est
une véritable nouveauté par rapport aux
différentes chartes qui peuvent déjà
être existence ce contrat d'engagement
républicain il a été élaboré dans sa
trame avec les élus et les associations
via deux savent de consultation l'une
avec les élus après avec sa collègue
jacqueline gourault et l'autre avec les
associations avec notre collègue sara el
hayani à l'immense majorité des
associations de mise aux intérêts bien
rappeler participe de l'offre
républicaine et citoyenne
mais grâce à ce contrat d'engagement
l'état et les collectivités auront un
outil juridique clair pour entraver
l'action de celle qu'ils entravent le
respect des principes de la république
c'est aussi respect de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes
les idéologies séparatistes vous le
savez elles ont pour devise et d'entravé
à la liberté et les droits des femmes
c'est c'est assez manifeste les
séparatistes et notamment les islamistes
que nous combattons ne supporte pas la
liberté des femmes qui préfigure la
liberté de la société dans son ensemble
nous nous considérons que toutes les
femmes qui vivent en france va pouvoir
bénéficier des mêmes droits à tous
doit pouvoir être protégés dans leur
intégrité et nous considérons que les
protéger c'est ne pas accepter pour
d'autres femmes ce que nous
n'accepterions pas pour nous mêmes pour
nos soeurs ou pour nos filles partant de
là nous considérons que les pratiques
dites coutumières elles n'ont pas leur
place en france
je veux parler là des mariages forcés la
polygamie la discrimination des filles
face à l'héritage la pratique des
certificats ou des tests de virginité
donc ce texte il vient compléter ce
qu'on appelle désormais les trous dans
la raquette avec cette expression
consumer pour pouvoir justement répondre
de façon juridique clair à ces pratiques
il ya des années de cela la france a eu
le courage de dire non à la pratique de
l'excision au pratique des mutilations
génitales et je crois qu'il est
important que la république française
pose des barrières et des interdits et
disent aujourd'hui le nom et stop aux
pratiques telles que celles des
certificat de virginité dans la droite
ligne de la diplomatie féministes qui
est menée par le président de la
république est d'ailleurs de nombreux
pays partout dans le monde regarde ce
qui se passe en france dans le cadre de
cette loi pour se fonder également sur
les avancées qui auront lieu en france
pour les droits des femmes pour les
exporter et y travailler également dans
leur propre pays
je crois que nous devons pouvoir dire
qu'aujourd'hui la république ne tolère
pas d'atteinte à la dignité humaine que
ce soit sur des femmes ou sur des hommes
et c'est ce que nous vous proposons avec
un chapitre que l'assemblée nationale a
souhaité rebaptisé est nommé respect des
droits des personnes et égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes dans ce
chapitre nous veillons donc à l'égalité
traitement entre les héritiers
si vous avez pas mal de deux questions
d'intervention sur sur ce sujet notre
but c'est très simplement que les filles
ne puisse plus être déshérités comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
eu égard à des failles dans le droit
international je vous remercie le garde
des sceaux notamment pour son engagement
très fort vis-à-vis de cette mesure
l'assemblée nationale a d'ailleurs
enrichi le texte à cet égard eu égard
recommandations qui ont été partagées
par l'ordre des notaires
nous instaurons dans ce texte également
une réserve générale de polygamie pour
la délivrance et pour le renouvellement
des titres de séjour
nous affirmons que les hommes de
nationalité étrangère qui sont coupables
de polygamie n'ont rien à faire dans
notre pays et nous souhaitons en
cohérence un accompagnement
un examen individuel dans le cadre du
renouvellement du titre de séjour pour
les femmes qui subissent cette situation
de polygamie et qui se verrait aux mises
en danger par les actions que j'ai cités
nous voulons ensuite interdire aux
professionnels de santé et d'établir des
certificats de virginité les
professionnels qui en délivreront seront
passibles de poursuites pénales
j'ai entendu différents débats
différentes interventions mais je veux
être très clair il nous sans que ce
n'est pas en produisant des certificats
virginité qu'on va mieux protéger les
jeunes filles il ya des certains en
grande majorité des gynécologues sont
très engagés et soutiennent cette mesure
d'une petite minorité s'est exprimé en
disant oui mais qu'est ce qui se passe
pour la jeune fille quand elle rentre
chez elle sans son certificat de
virginité
nous nous demandons ce qui se passe pour
la jeune fille qui rentre chez elle avec
son certificat de virginité sa dignité
de personne ne va probablement pas être
respecté dans la suite de ce mariage qui
est démarre par un test de virginité
donc il nous semble important de
protéger les jeunes filles qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables aux
pressions séparatiste l'assemblée
nationale a souhaité à cet égard
introduire une incrimination spécifique
des personnes qui incite au contraire
une femme a sollicité ce certificat de
virginité avec un quantum de peine
cohérent nous aurons l'occasion je crois
d'en débattre et de débats de cette
interdiction je ne crois savoir que nous
devons vous souhaitez que nous soyons
particulièrement attentifs à cette
mesure et je crois que l'écriture de
notre droit c'est aussi l'écriture de la
défense des femmes et qu'elle est
fondamentale nous allons renforcer de la
même manière la lutte contre les
mariages forcés en rendant obligatoire
la saisine du procureur de la république
par l'officier d'état civil en cas de
doute sérieux persistant sur le
consentement d'un des deux époux
d'ailleurs les élus locaux que nous
avons rencontrés et notamment
l'association des maires de france
qu'avec mes sionisme interne nous avons
reçu nous ont fait part du fait que les
élus sont souvent démunis face aux
situations de mariage forcé car la loi
ne leur donne pas les moyens à l'heure
actuelle d'agir véritablement et c'est
ce que nous ferons avec cette loi bien
sûr toutes ces dispositions elles
devront s'accompagner d'actions fortes
de politiques publiques la loi n'est pas
un quant à thouars ne se suffit pas à
elle-même nous avons déjà commencé à
travailler sur des politiques
interministériel
prix de soutien vis-à-vis des élus
locaux qui viennent soutenir la mise en
oeuvre de ce que nous allons je l'espère
discuter et que vous allez je l'espère
voter et enfin je voudrais appeler votre
attention sur le fait que les mises à
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et moi même
nous avons déposé deux amendements très
avec notre collègue ministre de la
transformation publics pour renforcer
les questions de laïcité dans le service
public
notre premier amendement il a prévu de
former à la laïcité tous les agents
publics crois que les événements de ces
derniers mois nous vous montrer qu'il y
avait un manque criant et je sais que le
sénat y est particulièrement attachée et
attentif et le second il vise à créer un
vrai réseau est un vrai maillage
territorial de référents laïcité dans
toutes les administrations publiques
l'assemblée nationale les a accueillis
favorablement je crois que ce sont de
bonnes mesures très concrètes et
j'espère que vous en partagerez la
volonté la laïcité c'est le ciment de
notre république et je crois qu'elle
doit être au coeur du service public je
sais que le sénat en tout cas il est
particulièrement attentif pourrais vous
dire pour conclure que je sais le
travail important que vous avez commencé
à mener au sénat notamment travers des
auditions et à travers un travail que
vous avez mené à eau par delà et
précédent les débats autour de cette
fois et je ne doute pas que nos débats
vont améliorer encore ce projet de loi
mais d'amener sénatrice et messieurs les
sénateurs je crois que c'est un projet
loi équilibrée qui préserve un certain
nombre d' équilibre notamment de liberté
raisonnable et surtout concrets qui a
pour but de véritablement d'apporter des
réponses aux acteurs de terrain et
singulièrement aux élus locaux
je pense là notamment à la question du
contrat d'engagement républicain qui
nous a été demandé par des élus qui à
l'heure actuelle quand ils veulent le
mettre en place sont parfois attaquer en
justice ou menacés victime de certaines
pressions communautaires je pense que
nous sommes là en train de créer des
outils qui vont véritablement leur
permettre de mieux agir sur le terrain
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci madame la ministre vien je vais
maintenant donner la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs madame eustache brinio où je
n'ai pas pour longtemps
le temps qu'il vous faut voilà merci
monsieur milices merci madame liste de
vos propos vous avez rappelé l'un et
l'autre le contexte dans lequel ce
projet de loi arrive au sénat
vous avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
le contexte très compliqué que nous
vivons tous ensemble alors avec
honnêteté c'est ce que nous vivons avec
sept islamistes cet islam politique nous
ne vivons pas depuis huit jours c'est
quelque chose qu'il sait distiller dans
notre pays depuis une vingtaine d'années
il faut vraiment avoir l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de le dire
sauf qu'aujourd'hui effectivement en
tout cas l'heure n'est plus aux
tergiversations mais à l'action j'ai
envie de dire voilà je pense que on peut
aussi partager avec vous un certain
nombre de constats qui fait en sorte
qu'ils font en sorte qu'aujourd'hui
cette nation se fracture et je voudrais
vous poser des questions enfin deux cas
vous interroger sur deux choses sur ce
texte
effectivement avec ma collègue nous y
travaillons beaucoup nous en sommes déjà
une cinquantaine d'heures d'audition
donc effectivement on y travaille
beaucoup
moi je suis interpellé par le texte
parce que je pars le titre pardon parce
que je ne suis pas sûr que pour nos
concitoyens ce titre soit très
révélateur de ce que vous voulez faire
sincèrement
alors peut-être que pour vous et pour
nous ça peut paraître clair mais pour
les habitants de ce pays
je ne suis pas sûr que le titre veuille
dire grand chose dans le combat que nous
avons à mener
je ne dis pas qu'il ne veut rien dire le
titre mais dans le combat que nous avons
à mener
vous avez partait monsieur mini c'est
madame ministre de laïcité il apparaît
pas beaucoup ce mot laïcité dans ce
texte
et je pense que vous avez comme moi pris
connaissance de l'article du point ce
matin qui peut quand même nous faire
peur aux uns et aux autres
sur ce que pensent aujourd'hui une
partie des lycéens de la laïcité et je
pense qu'on ne peut pas ne pas
s'interroger sur cet article
et sur cette enquête qui s'est passé ce
matin et justement pour en revenir au
contrat républicain dont vous parlez qui
me paraît une bonne chose il ya
d'ailleurs des villes des régions des
départements qui l'ont déjà fait signe
qu'ils ont déjà fait signer ce type de
document mais là effectivement il
conforte les choses le mot laïcité
n'apparaît jamais dans ce contrat
républicain pur c'est un petit peu
dommage parce que
la laïcité elle et mons et patrice selle
et intégratrice elle est porteur
d'espoir et du coup elle n'apparaît pas
du tout que ce mot n'apparaît pas je
voudrais aussi parler de la fermeture
des lieux de culte vous avez monsieur le
ministre rappeler qu'effectivement vous
vous donner des outils pour fermer des
lieux de culte on peut s'interroger
aussi sur la nécessité de fermer des
lieux de culte pourquoi pas
définitivement et ça c'est pas prévu
est ce qu'il ne serait pas intéressant
de fermer définitivement des lieux sous
des chaleurs avec vraiment des contextes
de discours qui portent atteinte à la
nôtre démocratie gens me dire parce que
ça va jusque là ça c'est pas prévu
est ce qu'il ne serait pas possible de
le prévoir il y a eu aussi rajouté un
article à l'assemblée sur la neutralité
des élus à titre personnel je suis très
attaché pourquoi ne vous n'êtes pas allé
plus loin sur la neutralité des élus
dans le cas de leurs fonctions je
rappelle bien donne la carte de leurs
fonctions c'est une question en tout cas
qui peut être intéressant de se poser et
dernière question et dernière analyse
aurez vous les moyens aurez vous les
moyens pour mettre en place tous ses
objectifs que vous fixez que nous
pouvons évidemment partagé mais qui va
demander beaucoup de moyens humains et
financiers pour y arriver
certes en huit jours certes ça prendra
du temps mais les moyens sont
nécessaires
merci madame aubé rien merci beaucoup
alors quelques questions monsieur le
ministre tout d'abord
sur la fermeture administrative des
lieux de culte effectivement aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit c'est soit parce que c
est harper soit c'est parce que cécile
était donc c'est contre le terrorisme
comment est ce qu'on arrive à assurer
l'équilibré en fermant un lieu de culte
aujourd'hui entre maintien de l'ordre
public et atteinte à la liberté de
conscience et au libre exercice des
cultes et par ailleurs vous disiez que
vous ne disposez pas de moyens pour
fermer les lieux de culte c'est vrai
mais il existe déjà l'article 35 de la
loi de 1905 qui permet pour le coup de
punir le ministre du culte qui
provoquerait a résisté à l'exécution des
lois ou aux actes légaux de l'autorité
publique
est-ce que cet article 35 vous l'avez
vous avez eu l'occasion de le faire
jouer puisque c'est une façon finalement
d'attaquer la tête du lieu de culte qui
pourrait déjà être utilisées donc sans
passé ni par sylt ni par le problème des
rp ensuite autre question sur le les
contraintes administratives et
comptables de cons mais aude 1901 qui
aurait une activité cultuelle
alors je voudrais dire que s'il ya
vraiment une chose importante dans ce
texte
et effectivement le fait de passer
l'activité cultuelle sous le contrôle
1905 et donc de faire que même les
associations qui resterait 10 901 phase
que la partie cultuelle soit
comptablement séparés et passe sous 2905
mais se pose quand même le problème des
activités cultuelles qui ne sont pas
régulières je pense à certaines
associations qui pourraient organiser
des messes mai mais ponctuellement je
pense aux scouts confessions enfin des
messes ou des cultes d'une façon
générale aux scouts confessionnelles aux
établissements de gestion d'activités
privées confessionnelles
le certaines activités caritatives
exceptionnelle qui confessionnel qui
pourrait faire une messe occasionnels
mais sans pour autant être vraiment une
activité cultuelle est ce que celles ci
devront séparer ça ou pas et comment est
ce qu'elles vont le gérer
enfin là cette fois je vais m'adresser à
vous madame la ministre sur alors c'est
jeu évidemment que on ne peut pas
valider les certificat de virginité les
tests de virginité encore moins que les
certificats d'ailleurs ce que je répète
le certificat est un papier le test est
effectivement intrusif la polygamie ou
on sait bien que c'est plutôt l'enfer
dans la famille
les mariages forcés l'excision on est
assez d'accord par contre la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on prévoit pas ce que
la meilleure façon de lutter c'est quand
même l'éducation
or on se rend compte que l'éducation
sexuelle à l'école et quand même quelque
chose de très difficile à appliquer qui
a justement c'est peut-être le premier
lieu des pressions et la répression qui
ne sont pas seulement musulmane
islamistes etc
je pense que d'autres religions peuvent
faire le même type de pression et puis
par ailleurs vous visez plus
spécifiquement les médecins mais comment
est ce qu'on va faire appliquer la loi
qui va nous dire que tel médecin fait
des certificat de virginité et comment
du coup faire appliquer cette loi est
est-ce que c'est pas contre-productif de
faire une loi qu'on ne saura pas faire
respecter voilà et puis
alors la dernière c'est plutôt une
remarque est ce qui montre la diversité
du travail sénatorial puisque moi
personnellement au niveau du titre je
suis assez attaché aux principes de la
république et je préfère qu'on parle de
la solution plus du problème mais c'est
une petite différence entre nous bien
merci mesdames alors chez le ministre
ma chemise puis madame la ministre et
ensuite j'aurai la parole aux autres
collègues qui l'ont demandé madame merci
se prétendent mesdames les sénatrices
madame jacqueline eustache brinio
peut-être pour vous répondre sur la
question du mode laïcité moi je veux
partager
nous partageons évidemment avec les
sionistes de l'intérieur votre
attachement aux mots de laïcité et au
delà du bon évidemment à sa valeur et à
ce qu ils recoupent et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi nous avons souhaité étendre
notamment la neutralité religieuse aux
dsp comme l'évoquait mise de l'intérieur
en ce qui concerne le contrat
d'engagement républicains pour être très
honnête avec vous on a vraiment mis sur
la table les différentes possibilités et
on les a travaillés d'un point de vue
juridique le mot de laïcité il existe à
l'heure actuelle dans un contrat
d'engagement républicain dans son
préambule ce qu il rappelle les
principes et donc le mot de laïcité et
nommer clairement au niveau des
préambules en revanche vous avez raison
il n'est pas nommé dans les obligations
et dans les principes à respecter pour
quelles raisons d'abord parce que
l'association et la subvention à une
association n'est pas justement une
délégation de service public et que
faire appliquer le principe de laïcité
pourrait sous-entendre de faire
appliquer un principe de neutralité
religieuse à une association
nous avons donc préféré le terme de
respect de la liberté de conscience qui
nous permet donc de bien lutter contre
tout phénomène d'emprise les phénomènes
de dérives sectaires mais aussi
évidemment prioritairement les
phénomènes de radicalisation connais
bien ces associations ce qu'on essaye de
jgc par exemple l'association qui
prétend faire du sport ou de l'aide aux
devoirs et qui en réalité fait de
l'endoctrinement et de la radicalisation
religieuse
en revanche si nous mettions le mot de
laïcité nous avons notre attention
étaient alertés sur le fait qu'il ya un
énorme risque très concrets que ça
puisse faire tomber toutes possibilités
de subventions à des organisations comme
la cimade le
secours catholique et d'autres qui ne
sont pas neutres religieusement dans
leurs activités c'est la réponse est l'
alerte que nous avons d'un certain
nombre de juristes d'un point de vue
notamment constitutionnel mais surtout
d'un point de vue de l'efficacité ne
voulons pas que ce contrat d'engagement
républicain il se retourne et qu'il
empêche l'état ou des collectivités
devenir subventionner ses activités je
pourrais citer aussi par exemple les
activités de scoutisme qui sont souvent
subventionnés et dont nous considérons
pas qu'elles représentent une menace
pour les questions de respect de la
république pour répondre peut-être à la
question relative à l'éducation aléas
pardon à l'éducation affective et
sexuelle à l'école de madame la
rapporteur dominique vergnes ans je
voudrais vous dire qu'effectivement
depuis 2014
la loi prévoit qu'il y ait trois séances
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle dans les écoles c'est le toit
elle n'a quasiment jamais été appliquée
jusqu'à l'an dernier nous avons avec
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans mes
précédentes fonctions passer la consigne
qu'elle soit désormais appliquée un
audit doit être réalisée à la fin de
l'année scolaire pour voir si c'est 3
séances d'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle sont véritablement appliquée
nous avons d'ailleurs lancé un plan de
lutte contre l'excision l'année dernière
pour justement faire des alertes
notamment au moment du printemps et de
l'été parce qu'on sait qu'à ce moment là
il ya un risque plus fort de prévalence
de ces mutilations sexuelles ou de toute
action au niveau de l'école mais je
crois qu'il ya effectivement une action
au delà de la loi de politiques
publiques et de contrôle de la politique
publique et de sa réalité au niveau des
écoles et vous avez tout à fait raison
de le souligner et moi je partage
complètement à cet objectif que vous
rappelez en revanche sur la vous vous
disiez madame la sénatrice sa manière à
porter ça va être ça va être difficile
on ne pourra pas faire appliquer la loi
je partage pas ce point de vue je pense
qu'on peut faire appliquer la loi
quand on veut s'en donner les moyens
particulièrement sur le certificat de
virginité que vous évoquiez pour moi il
ya deux aspects un premier aspect qui
est pédagogique et je les assume
parfaitement le fait c'est le message
que nous envoyons nous on a vu des
associations je pense à un regard de
femme aux gammes c'est à d'autres qui
nous ont dit bas qu'en fait elle avait
beaucoup de jeunes filles qui leur ont
dit ah mais en fait je m'interroge
sur cette pratique du certificat de
virginité ou du test de virginité
on a toujours fait ça mes cousines mes
soeurs ont fait ça et du coup maintenant
je m'interroge sur cette pratique et ça
génère des débats des discussions parce
que le débat a lieu d'un point de vue
politique et ça je pense que c'est
positif
ensuite il ya l'application de la loi
vous avez tout à fait raison la loi on
l'apprend pas uniquement pour sa portée
pédagogique évidemment mais pour qu'elle
soit appliquée et pour qu'elle soit
appliquée eh bien je crois qu'il y a
deux choses 1 la façon dont les médecins
s'engagent et de effectivement oui des
contrôles qui auront lieu la première
personne qui pourra dénoncer ces
certificat de virginité ce sont les
jeunes filles qui en sont les victimes
et les ong qui les accompagnent ce qu'on
observe c'est que très souvent ces
pratiques
elles sont accompagnées d'autres
pratiques et dans ces cas là on a
énormément de ong dont certaines auquel
on a confié une mission en parallèle du
projet de loi je pense à women to women
qui traduit les lois dans des langues
étrangères pour que les femmes qui sont
des primo arrivants depuis c'est aussi
comprendre ses droits et sans saisir
parce que c'est souvent de ça dont on
parle en ce qui le concerne et
certificat de virginité
moi je crois vraiment qu'on pourra faire
appliquer cette fois comme l'excision
sous le président jacques chirac le
gouvernement et la majorité de l'époque
avait décidé d'interdire l'excision et à
l'époque on leur disait parfois oui mais
ce sera pas applicable ou certains 10 mn
il vaut mieux faire des excisions entre
guillemets bien fait dans des cabinets
médicaux
bon alors évidemment à l'époque et je le
dis d'autant plus c'est pas du tout
donc quand politique je veux dire de
cette manière mais à l'époque le
gouvernement la majorité de l'époque ont
tenu bon et ont décidé d'interdire
l'excision est d'ailleurs maintenant
c'est un fondement de la diplomatie
féministes françaises et beaucoup de
pays notamment en afrique de l'ouest
regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce qui
se fait en france comme une pratique
positif contre les pratiques néfastes et
communautaires qui peuvent exister dans
ces délais mais merci mesdames les
rapporteurs sur le titre bon je te pas
rentrer dans votre nuances mais c'est
vrai que c'est important je ne nie pas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'au effectivement
comme la rapporteure on préfère la
solution c'est de problème mais enfin
c'est une grande j'ai entendu parfois
cette critique
c'est une grande habitude des textes de
loi de ne pas ouvrir la réalité
médiatique et politique en 2004 lorsque
le voile à l'école a été interdite tout
le monde sait que ça a été fait suite
notamment à ce qui s'est passé à creil
et le long mûrissement qui a lu la
classe politique on a banni c'était là
le titre était pas apte à dire le voile
à l'école
la vitre était bien un des mots
compliqués dont on a appris du temps
pour sa cité ostensible rappelez-vous le
sujet de 2004 était plus juridique et
dont le titre que politique en 2010
lorsqu'ils essaient fallu parce qu'il a
fallu interdire la burqa dans l'espace
public on a dit que c'était pour éviter
la dissimulation du visage public et bi
même en 1905
tout le monde savait que c'était pour
séparer bien évidemment l'église
catholique du pouvoir politique
je vais évidemment pas histoire
parlementaire que chacun connaît surtout
ici au sénat bien mieux que moi enfin
c'est la loi de séparation des églises
et de l'état
l'oca toujours peut-être une différence
madame la sénatrice mme amara porter
entre le mot juridique dont nous pensons
que madame le rapporteur qu'il s'agit
des solutions des principes républicains
sont la solution de problèmes
c'est pour ça qu'il faut les conforter
que
de te faire un titre de peut-être plus
plus politique mais j'entends votre
question et façon il appartient
évidemment parlement de changer les
titres des doigts s'ils le souhaitent
sur la laïcité
bon la laïcité certes le mot est quand
même utilisé plusieurs fois dans le
texte mais je voudrais faire remarquer
ici que d'abord et je moi aussi je suis
inquiet comme vous de ce que je peux
lire des instituts de sondage et chacun
le voit chacun qu au regard des
commentaires
mais d'abord s'entendre sur ce qu'est
vraiment la laïcité puisque j'ai un bac
à 50 nu dans la cité mais enfin
l'assemblée nationale nous a amenés à
voir les débats parfois nous nous
mettions pas tous et même au delà
derrière le mot et nous nous rangeons
évidemment à la définition de la laïcité
telle que les pères de la constitution
reprenant ainsi préambule de 46 ski en
prenant un certain nombre de vieilles et
disposition je rappelle d'ailleurs que
le mot laïcité n'est pas dans la loi de
séparation des églises et de l'état
pourtant on dit que c'est vrai la
laïcité là encore un titre qui ne
correspondait sans doute pas à
aujourd'hui le contexte est tel que le
conseil d'état le définit est telle que
je sens du conseil constitutionnel est
finie ces trois choses qui se retrouvent
dans ce texte
d'abord c'est la pluralité religieuse
ensuite c'est évidemment la liberté de
culte et enfin c'est la neutralité des
tas de ses agents à la puissance
publique et ses agents ce n'est pas
contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire ou à
redire
la discrétion dans l'espace public ça
c'est tout à fait défendable mais ce
n'est pas la définition de la laïcité
française et ce n'est pas le fait qu'une
religion doit plus adapté qu'une autre
non au contraire c'est le fait qu'on
accepte l'idée que la pluralité
religieuse existe et notamment la
liberté d'expression de ses opinions
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen prévoyant même que nul ne
peut être inquiété pour ses opinions
même religieuses qui prouvait déjà sans
doute que
le celui qui avait eu ce qu'on écrit la
libération droits de l'homme avait déjà
une vision un peu lointaine de la
religion même religieuse montrer sans
doute le danger que représentait parfois
l'idée religieuse et pour l'état la
religion est une opinion et rien de plus
donc la pluralité religieuse la liberté
de culte réalité de la puissance
publique et de ses agents elle est dans
le texte
donc le sujet à la laïcité est quelque
part partout dans ce texte un chapitre
entier sur la liberté de plus sur fermer
les cultes définitivement je constate
d'ailleurs les questions de même la
rapporteure suivante c'était plutôt
comment on équilibre au mieux donc voilà
donc en équipe revient d'abord parce qu
on part du principe qu'on ne peut pas
fermer des lits de culte définitivement
il se serait manifestement attentatoire
à la liberté fondamentale qu'est la
liberté de culte
deuxièmement ce n'est pas les murs qui
se radicalise et c'est les personnes qui
sont dedans je serai aux remarques il
s'est pas les murs qui sont salafistes
c'est les personnes qui sont dedans
bon donc la destination de lieux de
culte n'est pas une réponse en soir il
vaut mieux combattre ce qui porte le
discours même si parfois ça passe par la
fermeture d'un lieu de culte évidemment
temporaires 6 mois un débat loi plutôt
que considéré qu' une fois qu'on a fermé
le couteau n'a pas vu la personne qui
continuaient à apprécier des discours de
haine évidemment et troisièmement ça
c'est un point qui me paraît très très
important nous devons
bien comprendre ce que dit à joris
présence administrative est donc ce que
pourrait et ce serait terrible pour ce
texte connaître comme censure lorsque je
fais fermé par monsieur le préfet de la
seine-saint-denis la mosquée dite de
pantin parce que nous avons la preuve
par deux fois qu'il ya un lien direct
avec l'assassinât de monsieur pâtit que
dit le juge administratif
il regarde la disposition de fermeture
que propre effet de serre ni à ma
demande et ilan à considérant qu'ils
devraient tous nous interpeller
il a calculé le juge administratif le
nombre de kilomètres qu'il y avait entre
la fermeture de la mosquée de pantin et
le lieu de culte musulmans la plus
proche concluant que le musulman le plus
proche est à 12 km il en conclut la
liberté de culte des fidèles musulmans
de la ville de pantin n'est pas touchée
comme libertés fondamentales et donc que
l'acte prix pas misé intérieur et
proportionnée ça veut dire que s'il
était à 40 ou 50 km il reste sans doute
du sud en raison de doutes dit que oui
le milieu intérieur a raison d'y voir un
lien direct avec la laïcité terrorisme
mais que la liberté de culte est plus
important sans doute que les
dispositions que donc il faut vraiment
qu'on fasse très attention et alors on
peut regretter ce genre de deux
considérant m'enfin on voit bien que
c'est ce que je disais en introduction
des grands combats liberté d'expression
liberté de culte ordre public protection
natation s'entrechoquent dans ce texte
où dans ses dispositions et qu'elles ne
sont pas simples et que la volonté du
miz l'intérieur comme j'imagine de ceux
qui sont en aspiration gouvernementales
qu'ils soient de la majorité ou de
l'opposition s'est abstenue n'importe
quoi est à voir son texte censuré ni au
conseil constitutionnel ni de m'en
occuper c'est ni après demain par une
cour européenne sur la neutralité de des
élus et dans le cadre de leurs fonctions
c'est un débat qui nous a occupés
longuement à l'assemblée nationale ça
dépend ce qu'on appelle neutralité il
est évident que aujourd'hui si je parle
de l'élu municipal qui est le seul
finalement lorsqu'il est maire ou
adjoint au maire à agir en tant
qu'officier d'état civil est donc en
tant qu'agent de l'état et donc à ce
titre le maire qui marie lemaire qui a
son écharpe bleu blanc rouge qui est
officier d'état civil
il doit avoir une neutralité bien sûr
mais lorsqu'il prit
le conseil municipal il n'est pas tenu à
cette neutralité il n'est pas officier
d'état civil
il n'est pas agent de l'état il est dans
l'organe délibérant et la loi
d'aujourd'hui peut-être faut-il le
rappeler c'est que lorsque l'élu
municipal à une délégation d'état civil
une délégation de représentants d'états
il est comme tous les autres tenues à la
neutralité politique et religieuse
il n'a pas le droit de donner son avis
politique dans un mariage et on peut pas
imaginer amer portant une kippa ou une
femme à voile lorsqu'elle marie déjean
mais en même temps il est évident qu'un
autre réalité ne s'entend pas que
rejette son temps si politiquement que
serait un élu qui aurait une neutralité
politique tout le temps et ce serait
drôle début puisque par définition il
fait aussi de la politique alors
derrière ce débat de neutralité il y
avait la question de savoir si on devait
interdire des élus d'aller dans des
dieux avec des messes
c'est le connaissez la tradition du
général de gaulle pourtant grand fervent
catholique qui n'a jamais communier
devant tout le monde
bon c'est vrai que c'est sans doute une
tradition républicaine que chacun
devrait respecter mais que serait cette
police qui imaginerait de pouvoir faire
des amendes au maire aux élus aux
conseils régionaux parlementaire
évidemment parce qu'ils aient envie le
dimanche soit deux communes et ce n'est
pas commune et si je prends l'exemple
l'église catholique
si je vais à tourcoing et que je
communie sais que mon droit le plus
strict est ce que je le fais surtout si
je fais le jour des élections
est ce que je le fais en sondant les
âmes et les coeurs parce que je sais que
les élections et que je parle avec toi
catholique et tout le monde entre
guillemets veut cogner à l'église de
tourcoing ce que je fais en tant que
citoyen dont je crois que vraiment la
position du normand ça sera de rester
très calme sur cette question même si on
comprend qu'elle pose d'autres questions
qu'est d'aller dans des lieux de culte
pour faire du communautarisme électorale
on voit bien la difficulté mais il n'est
pas interdit à un élu quelqu'il soit
d'aller dans un lieu de culte et je ne
crois pas qu'il faille interdire ça a
parfois été les dispositions présentées
par des parlementaires notamment la
france est soumise à l'assemblée
nationale il nous paraît important
cependant de mettre ce que nous avons
pris dans le texte de loi la possibilité
de mieux condamner ceux qui utilisaient
le culte pour y faire des réunions
politiques qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
nationaux
vous prenez des sports à étrangères
bravo l'occasion d'en reparler pas ce
que ça peu sera évidemment l'hémicycle
comme ça à passionner l'assemblée
nationale aurons nous les moyens je le
crois je le crois parce qu'aujourd'hui
on s'évertue à table beaucoup de temps
alors qu'on n'a pas les mesures
administratives pour le faire donc
évidemment larmes sera plus efficace
frère fait remarquer que c'est ce
gouvernement qui a doublé les effectifs
de la dgsi et des renseignements
territoriaux et le séparatisme et d'une
finalité désormais des renseignements
monde aura l'occasion pour nous d'en
reparler des lieux de culte mais
nombreux public
évidemment c'est un équilibre vous aurez
constaté d'ailleurs madame la
rapporteure que nous allons proposer
trois mois
c'est un débat que nous avons eu
notamment que le rapporteur de
l'international pour ce qui était de
l'action que nous voulons mener 3 nous
paraissait raisonnable notamment six
étaient renouvelables et je dis aussi
madame le rapporteur de ne pas se
focaliser que sur le lieu de culte mais
de se focaliser aussi sur l'association
puisque nous pouvons jouer désormais si
la loi est adoptée à la façon le lieu de
culte que l'on peut fermer et sur
l'association que l'on peut dissoudre ou
suspendre évidemment à l'écouté souvent
pas toujours mais très souvent gérée par
une association ce qui permet répondre à
ma disposition à votre question d'après
1900 en 1905
c'est évidemment très important la
volonté du gouvernement c'était que tout
le monde devait passer en 1905 avec
imaginons quelques années de transition
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
en 1905 les avantages et des
inconvénients à 1900 à aujourd'hui a
quasiment pas d'inconvénient à 1900 et
ce qui fait qu'il ya une sorte de
violation du droit 901 qui est de
confondre le cultuel du culturel et
parfois de toucher des subventions voir
des recettes fiscales de de déductions
fiscales
alors qu'on fait du culte parce qu a pas
d'étapes séparés qui a pas de compte
bancaire séparé et que ya tout un tas de
difficultés et que c'est beaucoup plus
simple de faire 1904 1905 et que 92 %
notamment des lieux de culte aujourd'hui
musulmans sont en 1901 le conseil d'état
nous a clairement dit que si nous
faisions ça nous faisons
une atteinte disproportionnée à la
liberté de culte dont je rappelle que la
loi ne définit pas ce qu'un ministre du
culte
la loi ne définit pas ce qu'est un culte
et j'ai fini pas même pas ce qu'est un
lieu de culte donc quand vous évoquez un
cerneau disposition des bradeurs au jeu
n'a pas souhaité rentrer dedans parce
qu'un culte nous connaissons les grands
cultes médiatique
si je veux dire que vous auditionnerait
sans doute enfin il y en a des centaines
de culte en france et nous n'avons pas
nous puisqu'il s'agit d'une opinion la
religion à distinguer ce qu'un culte et
ce n'est pas un culte
si les musulmans nous explique que les
imams ne sont pas des ministres du culte
ce qu'ils sont effectivement pas au sens
chrétien du terme ne plaquent ont pas me
semble-t-il
en tout cas c'est pas le rôle de l'état
neutre et laïque ce qu'est ou ce n'est
pas un ministre du culte
donc nous avons écouté le conseil d'état
nous avons fait le choix avec lui de
dire bon voilà on peut toujours géré la
culture 1901 ne le regrettons c'est une
liberté mais nous mettons tous les
inconvénients de 1905 1906 mettre les
avantages et en 1905
on met les avantages de 1901 bay à 1905
et donc on accepte l'idée que et un
bureau constitué de manière différente
que 1901 plus compliqué plus
contraignant d'ailleurs dans lequel on
dit personne ne peut y avoir été
condamné pour terrorisme ou est-ce que
vous affichez de ce type dans 1905 c'est
une disposition nouvelle
nous disons qu'il faut un
expert-comptable désormais parmi les
récriminations des cultes est évidemment
le fait qu on alourdit leur disposition
de comptabilité enfin ça ne paraît
nécessaire pour pouvoir au moins fait
renaître les reçus fiscaux
j'étais ministre des conflits pendant
trois ans je peux vous assurer que les
reçus fiscaux sont des choses et moins
contrôlés dans les associations et
singulièrement dans les lieux culturels
j'ai même fait dissoudre deux
associations cci a fait part à cassis ti
qui le jour même de leur dissolution
concédé mise pouvait encore émettre des
reçus fiscaux c'est quand même un peu
étonnant à dire ça comme ça et puis
troisièmement il ya tout un tas de
dispositions qui permettent
effectivement de renforcer le contrôle
que nous avons notamment des
financements étrangers dans 1905 et que
nous avons quelqu'un à 1901
donc l'idée c'est tous les avantages de
gérer un lieu cultuel par exemple de ne
pas payer d'impôts locaux
moi j'ai les associations musulmanes de
ma commune sont déjà venus voir pour
demander de l'argent public pour payer
la taxe foncière qui étaient importantes
je ne pouvais évidemment pas leur donner
en vertu de votre séparation est
empruntée
argent à l'étranger pour payer taxes
foncières s'il avait été en 1901 créée
en 1905 et 1911 il n'aurait pas payé la
taxe foncière passe que 2009 soit sur
1905 ne payent pas de fiscalité locale
pour la propriété des personnes
qui gère des lieux de culte par exemple
donc voila nous aurions aimé tout
bascule en 1905
le juge de qui conseille le gouvernement
a expliqué que ce serait à coup sûr une
censure
nous avons accompagné vers une
disposition qui apparaît proportionnée
au juge administratif et je pense que ce
serait une bonne mesure et que toulon
serait convaincu 1905 je veux ici dire
qu'évidemment les catholiques qui n'ont
pas reconnu 1905 qui ont demandé
d'ailleurs même au parlement assez
rapidement puisqu'on a eu en 1907 dès la
fin 2009 106 d'avoir un certain nombre
d'associations diocésaine reconnu
ensuite par des échanges épistolaires et
diplomatiques entre le gouvernement de
la république et le pape sont considérés
comme des 1905 et qui ne sont en aucun
cas concerné par les dispositions de
vesle que nous présentons ici les
catholiques font partie des associations
cultuelles bien évidemment même si l'akp
l'histoire de notre pays
les amis alors a fait mettre un petit
peu de temps avant de rentrer dans la
disposition voulue par par un résident
de parole c'est brillant dernier point
vous évoquez article 35 ans dirai ce que
tout ça est bien nécessaire notamment
pour la police du culte indique 35 en
1905 madame lasserre à porter en fait
jamais été utilisé par aucun
gouvernement
et pour cause je vais lire l'article 35
si un discours prononcé ou un écrit
affiches et distribuer plus uniquement
dans des lieux où s'exerce le culte
contient une provocation directe à
résister à l'exécution des lois ou aux
actes légaux de l'autorité publique ou
s'il tend à soulever ou armée une partie
des citoyens contre les autres le
ministre du culte qui en sera rendue
coupable sera puni d'un emprisonnement
de trois mois à deux ans
jusqu'ici on peut à peu près d'accord
encore faut-il définir ce qu'est
ministres du culte mais imaginons et la
phrase d'après ne manque pas de sel
explique pourquoi personne à utiliser en
115 ans
sans préjudice des peines de la
complicité dans le cas où la provocation
était suivie d'une sédition révolte ou
guerre civile
donc comme pour l'instant aucun discours
d'eau car son sable du culte n'a mené
pour l'instant à la sédition la guerre
civile
aucun gouvernement n'a plus dix articles
35 avant que même qu'un ministre qui
amènerait à la guerre civile corée qu'un
an d'emprisonnement ce serait quand même
une peine peu proportionnée c'est nous
qui nous apparaît nécessaire de mettre à
jour la loi de 1905 sur ce point
merci monsieur le ministre j'ai
plusieurs demandes de parole c'est
exactement mon nom je vous parle
monsieur jean pierre sueur monsieur
danny watts de blé madame maryse carrère
monsieur stéphane le rudulier madame
valérie boyer madame lherbier et enfin
madame de la gontrie
monsieur sûr vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre
plus nous travaillons sur cette loi ce
projet de loi
plus nous nous demandons finalement eu
s'il aura de l'effet parce que nous
avons reçu les représentants des cultes
comme vous même qui nous ont dit mais
dans ce pays où finalement la liberté de
religion existe où il est clair que
l'état n'a pas pour mission d'organiser
les cultes il y à toute une série de
contraintes qui arrive par exemple les
représentants des protestants nous ont
dit mais pourquoi diable nous impose ton
tout ça est ce vraiment nécessaire
alors c'est une question qui revient
tout le temps est ce nécessaire et je
comprends bien que vous voulez inciter à
ce que des associations 1901 se
transforme pour adhérer à l'association
mais on se demande en lisant le texte
quelles dispositions vont faire qu'elles
vont être incités à passer de 1901 en
voilà alors j'ai encore une ou deux
questions eu l'ordre public
il est parlé d'ordre public dans un
article relatif aux compétences ils ont
des as des des institutions cultuelles
moi je crois monsieur le ministre que
c'est vous quoi l'ordre public
les associations cultuelles n'ont pas
pour mission de gérer l'ordre public
parce que vous en pensez mais bon il
suffit qu'elles respectent les lois de
la république
à cet égard
il ya une question qui a déjà été posée
par madame la rapporteure et qui a été
posée hier par une audition que nous
avons entendu il y a quelqu'un dans une
mosquée puisque c'est le cas qui tient
des propos par exemple raciste bon
contraire à la loi
donc il est normal que cette personne
soit sanctionné parce que le racisme
n'est pas une opinion c'est un délit
simplement est ce que c'est un critère
pour fermer l'établissement
parce que si vous fermez l'établissement
et qu'après les tribunaux administratifs
décide d'annuler votre décision
ça va être naturellement pire donc à
partir de quel moment on va dire que
c'est pas un propos individuelle et qui
comme telle mérite d'être sanctionné
mais qu'il faut interdire la communauté
disons le lieu et les participants
compte tenu que les participants peuvent
dire mais nous on n'est pas responsable
de ses propos voilà j'avais encore une
question mais j'ai déjà assez parlé
pour savoir si vous tenez vraiment à
cette histoire d'immeubles de rapport
mais c'est peut-être lié une sorte de
didier alisme qui est le mien j'ai un
peu l'idée quoique les religions sont là
pour des questions spirituelles que
c'est déjà très très prenant à ces
questions-là immeubles de rapport bon
est ce que c'est vraiment l'objet quoi
bon mais j'ai peut-être tort et
peut-être que cette préoccupation
monsieur le ministre et angélique auquel
cas il faudra me pardonner merci
messieurs sur monsieur mateu blé merci
monsieur b dans le sionisme
ma question se rapporte à l'école
publique qui obligatoire gratuite et
laïque et qu'ils creusaient la
république
en effet l'association des plus jeunes
commencent en son sein et on y apprend
la langue française la maîtriser les
feux à fondamentaux l'histoire de france
est en fait c'est en allant à l'école
que nous en apprenons être franc c'est
pourquoi ajouté article 24 de ce projet
de loi qui prévoit la mise en place d'un
encadrement des contrôles plus fort de
l'instruction en famille
l'état de santé de l'enfant les visions
de pratique sportive vers tixier des
régions géographiques à l'existence du
site propre à l'enfant mais je me pose
de question pour quelle raison 7000
semble application si cette loi est
adoptée n'aurait lieu qu'en 2024 et
quelles mesures supplémentaires comptez
vous prendre pour aider les mères dans
leur mission de contrôle puisque ça
retombe toujours sur les locaux et je
reprendrai quelque chose qui est venu
par madame le rapporteur concernant la
section civique dans le temps on avait
quand même la sauce chili qu est-ce qu
il ya pas quelque chose de pédagogie car
ajouté au niveau de l'école c'est
l'endroit même où on peut prendre les
enfants plus bas âge et leur donner de
cette notion de laïcité et c'est
peut-être un peu volé qui manque dans
cette dans cette profession de loi de
peut-être en rapport avec l'hymne
national d'avoir un lien puisque je
pense que les enfants à certaines âge
sont plus réceptifs en dehors du lieu
familial pour comprendre ce que c'est
que la laïcité
je vous remercie madame maryse carrère
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la ministre je mesure la
difficulté aujourd'hui pour un texte tel
que celui que vous présentez de
préserver un équilibre entre les
libertés de culte les libertés de se
réunir en association et le respect des
principes de la loi de notre république
mais aussi le fil du rasoir sur lequel
on peut être tout le temps entre la
liberté de culte et son contrôle pour le
groupe rdse qui porte depuis sa création
la laïcité dans son adn et je
rappellerai pas ici les travaux de et
les combats de ma collègue françoise
laborde de notre ancien collègue sur ses
causes là et notamment sur les violences
faites aux femmes jeu
pense que nous avons été tous choqués
par ce que a rappelé notre rapporteur le
sondage ifop qui est sorti ce matin où
on a plus d'un lycéen sur deux qui se
dit favorable au port des signes
religieux ostensibles dans les lycées
publics deux fois plus que la population
sur la population des lycéens 49% ne
voit aucun inconvénient à ce que les
agents publics affichent leurs
convictions religieuses
on se rend compte que là on est sur une
conception très minimaliste de la
laïcité et on se rend compte aussi que
la religion n'est plus perçu comme un
corpus de valeurs auxquelles on croit
mais plutôt comme une une partie
complète de son identité
et ça ça nous arrive à nous gêner
aujourd'hui et nous partageons avec le
groupe rdse une bonne partie des
propositions que vous faites dans ce
projet de loi même si je pense qu il
manque d'ambition sur une partie qui est
la valeur éducative on paye aujourd'hui
30 ans d'abandon éducatif de cette
valeur fondamentale
ce texte ne reflète pas mon avis
suffisamment cette ambition éducative
forte en matière d'apprentissage de la
laïcité
aussi ma question elle est toute simple
quelle mesure au delà de ce texte se
rendent prévu à l'avenir pour pub pour
pallier ce manque
merci monsieur le régulier merci
monsieur monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre
effectivement c'est un projet de loi qui
qui répond à une situation donnée à une
urgence même de préserver notre notre
vivre ensemble et lutter contre toutes
les formes de séparatisme
gevrey souhaiterais vous vous interrogez
sur la distorsion entre les objectifs
initiaux qu'elle était affichée et la
version du projet de loin que vous nous
soumettez à savoir dans des versions
antérieures il était question de lutte
contre le terrorisme de lutte contre
l'islamisme radical contre le
séparatisme pour aboutir enfin
conforter les principes de la république
alors faut-il voir dans cette définition
différentes définitions successives de
ce projet de loin une espèce de fausse
pudeur ou une certaine forme
d'appréhension pour ne pas diviser notre
notre société et puis d'un point de vue
plus constitutionnel vous l'avez rappelé
dans vos propos monsieur le ministre le
projet de loi touche à certaines de nos
libertés fondamentales vous avez parlé
de la liberté d'association de culte
d'association est en fait en renonçant
peut-être à l'objectif initial on
élargissant le spectre
n'avez vous pas la crainte d'une censure
constitutionnelle plus forte sur
certaines dispositions et n'aurait-il
pas été plus plus sage tout simplement
d'adopter la proposition de loin
constitutionnel issu de notre assemblée
pour inscrire notamment dans la loi
fondamentale que nul ne peut s'exonérer
de la règle commune au titre de son
origine ou de sa religion
et puis à sa guise de conclusion mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec le projet de loin
et son examen vous avez eu la
gentillesse vendredi dernier de devenir
dans ma belle commune de rognac pour
l'inauguration de la brigade
territoriale autonome de gendarmerie
je vous sais trés trés attaché notamment
au confort des forces de l'ordre vous
l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé dans dans
votre propos je voudrais vous remercier
vivement de votre présence je voudrais
vous dire que je regrette vivement que
je n'ai pas je ne puisse pas recevoir
une invitation pour participer à cette
cérémonie
merci monsieur nice est liée à boyer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'avais beaucoup de questions
mais je voudrais évoquer avec vous la
lutte contre les mariages frauduleux
prévu à l'article 17
je me permets de rappeler lorsque j'ai
déposé à l'assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi le 21 février 2018
sur ce sujet j'ai fait l'objet de
d'attac
plusieurs partis politiques et de votre
majorité
lorsque j'ai proposé des amendements sur
ce sujet dans la loi asile immigration
on a voulu faire croire que c'était un
épiphénomène votre prédécesseur gérard
collomb a même rejeté des propositions
qui sont aujourd'hui reprises dans votre
texte
je m'en réjouis mais je pense notamment
au fait de rendre obligatoire la saisine
du procureur de la république en cas de
doute sur la sincérité du mariage et je
me félicite de voir qu'une nouvelle fois
encore ce qui n'était pas possible
hierle est aujourd'hui j'ose espérer
monsieur le ministre que ce sont nos
propositions qui sont systématiquement
rejetées pour être reprise quelques
semaines après ne le sont pas par
posture pâtit partisanes car à chaque
silence sur les mariages frauduleux
c'est une situation humainement honteuse
que nous cautionnons c'est une
organisation de trafic d'êtres humains
que nous encourageons nous estimons
d'ailleurs à plusieurs milliers le
nombre de mariages blancs ou gris
contracté chaque année en france
à titre de comparaison la belgique
empêche 7000 union suspecte par an
malheureusement en france ne dispose pas
de statistiques à ce sujet nous savons
que les mariages concernent près de 24%
des cas de naturalisation en 2019 contre
21% en 2010 est je le rappelle en 2019
plus de 112 mille étrangers sont devenus
français
parmi eux 27 mille ont été naturalisés
suite à un mariage avec un ressortissant
français
en effet la naturalisation concerne 112
mille personnes en 2019 dont 27 mille
suite à un mariage
nous savons également que ces dernières
années les mariages mixtes ont gagné du
terrain
ils représentent aujourd'hui 27% selon
l'insee les mariages mixtes représentait
6% des unions célébrées en france en
1950 contre 14 % en 2015
ces statistiques sur les mariages mixtes
réflète pardon les flux migratoires en
france
c'est pour cela que 37% des unions
mixtes célébrés dans notre pays en 2015
on unit un conjoint français avec une
personne de nationalité du magret
m 22 % avec un français yann européen
14% avec un français et ressortissants
d'afrique sub saharienne
concernant les mariages frauduleux selon
certains officiers d'état civil repris
par certains médias les pays les plus
représentés par ces mariages varie selon
les villes et j'en viens à ma question
parce que nous ne disposons pas de
statistiques officielles la tunisie
l'algérie et le maroc sont concernés
tout comme haïti certains pays d'afrique
ainsi que des pays d'europe de l'est est
aussi notamment dans le cadre des
mariages gris encore la chine ou le
vietnam et vous savez que ces mariages
se monnaye et ce modèle extrêmement cher
pourtant en france nous ne savons pas
combien de mariages frauduleux sont
célébrés ni combien sont annulés chaque
année est d'ailleurs en tant que maire
pour ce qu'ils ont fait des signalements
moi j'avais relaté mon expérience je
n'avais jamais eu de réponse de la part
de la préfecture lorsque j'avais signalé
des mariages qui pouvait sembler suspect
c'est à dire que nous avons une fin de
non recevoir de la part du préfet en
tout cas ça a été le cas lorsque j'ai
été maire ma question est la suivante
est ce que nous sommes en mesure de
savoir combien il ya de mariages blancs
ou gris aujourd'hui et où sont ils
répartis et quelle nationalité cela
concerne je voudrais aussi savoir si
nous comme pour comment connaître la
nationalité des personnes qui se
trouvent en situation irrégulière sur
notre territoire et j'aimerais vraiment
monsieur le ministre à avoir des
réponses à ces questions je ne les ai
pas eus lorsque je les ai posé
précédemment mais peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui à la faveur de ce texte
on pourrait les obtenir je vous remercie
boyer verviers oui monsieur le président
j'ai deux questions une pour monsieur le
ministre et une pour madame
personnellement je suis très favorable à
une réaction il faut réagir
c'est la première fois où j'ai eu ce
sentiment c'était
au forum international de lutte contre
la cybercriminalité de la gendarmerie
le forum international il y en a tous
les ans depuis 15 ans à lille
et tous les ans les gendarmes nous
montrent qu'ils peuvent lutter contre la
radicalisation contre la haine en ligne
contre les réseaux cyber criminels la
plupart du temps ils nous disent qu'ils
manquent de personnel qui manque de deux
ils peuvent recruter des ingénieurs ils
peuvent recruter des tas de personnes
cyber spécialistes mais il faut leur
donner les moyens
la france n'est pas toute seule on le
voit lors de ces juste échange de
gendarmerie ma question monsieur le
ministre est de savoir si vous avez des
objectifs européens notamment dans ce
cadre de de lutte contre la cyber
sécurité en ligne
si vous avez des pistes à exploiter avec
nos partenaires européens concernant ce
genre de lutte
la deuxième question concerne madame
cher pas vous savez j'étais enseignant
toute ma vie j'ai vu des étudiants
partir en vacances et ne pas revenir au
mois de septembre
parce que j'ai été mariée de force et
vous doutez bien que votre sujet
m'interpelle vivement j'ai déposé avec
ma collègue bon fantine une ppl
concernant justement les mariages forcés
et pour que ça ne soit pas seulement de
la prévention mais aussi de la sanction
pour celui qui qui exploite ce genre de
situation alors moi madame je me pose la
question de savoir si les médecins vont
vont jouer le jeu pour les certificat de
virginité ça il n'y a pas que les
certificats jay virginité moi quand
j'étais conseillère générale je
m'apercevais qu'il y avait beaucoup de
sous le cadre du secret médical les
médecins nous le disait anonymement
mais il y avait des demandes de
reconstruction de l'hymen et ça c'était
très très fréquent leur demande est très
très souvent et il le faisait par devant
les supplications de 2
des jeunes filles qui se voyait
complètement perdus si elle n'avait pas
cette cette reconstruction
alors je voudrais savoir madame si vous
pensez comment vous allez réagir
vis-à-vis des médecins certes une
interdiction du certificat de de
virginité mais il n'ya pas que ça c'est
le merdier
madame de la gontrie ensuite le chef
bellelay et monsieur philippe bas on
laissera les ministres répondent merci
monsieur le président de 2,2 points
le premier c'est que effectivement ce
texte peut laisser un petit peu perplexe
dans le sens où nous avions compris
qu'il était inspirée du discours des
bureaux du président de la république et
c'est vrai qu'on ne retrouve pas
l'ensemble de ce qui avait pu être
annoncé ce jour là alors j'ai vu vous
aviez déjà été interrogé sur ce point et
que vous y répondiez que ce texte est
une partie de ce qui était évoqué lors
du discours des mureaux n'empêche que il
n'y a rien ici qui peut traiter de
l'ensemble des promesses de la
république
or c'est bien quand même ce qui laisse
penser ce que laisse penser le titre
puisqu'il n'y a rien sur les droits
sociaux les droits économiques la mixité
scolaire
bref en revanche c'est un texte
extraordinairement normatif pour
utiliser un terme neutre ce qui touche à
de nombreuses libertés ça a été évoqué
tout à l'heure par nos collègues
association conscience culte réunion
opinion communication presse libre
administration des collectivités locales
et enseignement donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est un petit peu mal à l'aise face au
spectre général et à la lecture qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir de ce texte
ensuite une question c'était plus une
remarque une question plus précise
il y a dans ce texte un article
18 et qui va nécessairement en tout cas
qui cohabitent jusqu'à ce jour dans le
débat parlementaire avec l'article 24 du
texte que vous porter aussi ça tombe
bien
pourtant il va bien falloir que ces deux
textes s'articule parce que le principe
de la légalité des délits et des peines
fait que ça s'impose à nous nous devons
avoir une rédaction qui soit claire
puisqu'il faut un texte pénal précis et
clair pour que les dispositions soient
valides
donc nous allons nous trouver demain
géant veut dire indépendamment de la
rédaction de l'article 24 sorties de
l'assemblée nationale vous savez que le
sénat et ont adopté cette modification
ce matin une nouvelle rédaction va
sortir du périmètre global c'est que
l'article 24 nouvelles formules va-t-on
dire version sénat sera plus étroit je
fais ça à grands traits que le futur
article 18 n'empêche que les champs
d'application vont être concurrents donc
ma question est une question de comment
dire de voile à 2,10 d'histoire
parlementaire
c'est à dire qu'il va bien falloir au
bout du bout qu'il y ait une seule
incrimination applicables de manière
précise aux infractions concernées donc
vous êtes porteur des deux textes
comment pensez-vous articuler ce
concours d'infractions prévues dans deux
textes différents
merci madame charlotte bellet et merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre de questions une
observation une première question à
l'article 27 du texte le préfet peut
s'opposer au caractère à la
reconnaissance du caractère cultuel
d'une association loi 1901 qui accomplit
la procédure il peut le faire en
utilisant trois arguments deux sont très
objectif le troisième est été est prévu
ce sont des motifs d'ordre public
moi je ne sais pas définir les motifs
d'ordre public et je me pose la question
je veux la partager avec vous voir si on
introduit pas là une forme de
subjectivité pas d'arbitraire une forme
de subjectivité une petite inquiétude
légistique second point et avec le même
angélisme que notre collègue sueur moi
je je ne vois pas effectivement pourquoi
on interdirait à des associations parce
qu'elles sont cultuel de ne pas acquérir
et de ne pas administrer des biens de
rapports comme d'autres associations
peuvent le faire je ne me dérange
absolument pas et est au contraire et
avec le même angèle et je me demande
pourquoi on interdirait l'acquisition à
titre onéreux à ces associations là on
peut imaginer que une association
cultuelle dispose d'un bien qui lui a
été donnée elle le vend parce qu'elle
n'a plus l'usagé
et elle souhaite réinvestir dans un
autre ça me choquerait absolument pas
qu'on le permettent
qu'en pensez vous monsieur le monsieur
le ministre et enfin une observation le
un questionnaire commun à l'ensemble des
collectivités est prévu une ça me semble
une amélioration très positif delà de la
lutte contre les mariages qui
connaissent un vice du consentement ou
une absence de contraintes ou une
contrainte par dont plusieurs maires
m'ont dit avoir pris la peine d'élaborer
ces questionnaires et de signaler au
procureur de leur territoire un des
mariages contestable pour ces motifs
plusieurs m'ont dit le procureur nous a
appelés pour nous dissuader ils ont
répondu écrivait le mois le procureur en
conséquence dans les mois qui ont suivi
a systématiquement autorisé dans le
délai de 15 jours la célébration des
mariages et ce dispositif est améliorée
à l'article 17
je me demande dès lors enfin je voulais
signaler que dès lors que le procureur
en l'espèce est plutôt le représentant
de l'état semble-t-il ça ne mérite pas
une remobilisation des gardes par le
garde des sceaux qui me suffit pas
merci monsieur le président madame et
monsieur les ministres il ya dans votre
texte plusieurs dispositions que je suis
prêt à voter
il y en a d'autres que je ne voterai pas
mais au delà de ses dispositions
ponctuelles sur lesquels nous aurons
bien sûr nous prononcer j'ai une
question plus générale sur la proche
politique qui est la vôtre
nous sommes tous eu je crois ou
probablement presque tous d'accord sur
cette idée qu'il faut assurer une
séparation étanche entre culte et
politiques près d'ailleurs au coeur de
la loi de 1905
vous espérez faire sortir les salafistes
des mosquées mais alors où iront ils
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que la
combinaison de la liberté de réunion et
de la liberté d'expression leur
permettre de se tourner vers d'autres
lieux que les mosquées pour répandre
leur propagande
et si tel devait être le cas
quels sont les instruments que vous
proposez pour empêcher cette dérive au
fond qui ferait passer le salafisme des
mosquées à salafisme des salles de
réunion sans gêner le moins du monde
cette propagande qui se répand nous
serions en quelque sorte mieux protéger
contre l'intrusion du politique dans les
lieux de culte que contre la diffusion
d'une idéologie subversive
en dehors des lieux de culte et je me
demande comment on peut traiter ce
problème je vous je vous le dis parce
que je crois que ça mérite débat entre
nous parce que on risque d'avoir en bété
tous les cultes sans distinction il pose
aucun problème à la république pour un
résultat qui seraient en fin de compte
absolument dérisoires
dans notre volonté de faire reculer le
séparatisme alors je ne partage pas
l'angélisme du président sueur ou de mon
collègue de bellelay mais je dois vous
dire que je ne partage n'ont pas non
plus le vôtre et alors il me reste une
personnalité qu'à demander l'accueil
ainsi une sénatrice madame benbassa et
après vraiment j'arrête pour laisser la
parole au ministre madame benbassa
m'entendais très bien
bonjour oui merci monsieur le président
je voudrais poser de questions la
première c'est sur la transformation de
l'article baumann sait et qui prévoit
que chef d'association cultuelle
déclarent tous les cinq ans au préfet de
sa qualité cultuelle celui ci ayant deux
mois pour donner ou non son accord
cette exigence s'ajoutent n'est ce pas
la déclaration préfectorale habits
habituel et qui est doublée d'une
réévaluation quinquennal de cette
qualité culturelle et qui serait une
régression étonnante et je cite la
cheville de rang ce qui m'a inscrit à ce
sujet et ce sont ses mots et je viendrai
à donner aux préfets la charge de
reconnaître ou non un culte en tant que
tel ce qui est tout le contraire de ça
de ce qu'a voulu la république avec la
loi de séparation
je voudrais aussi avoir plus de détails
sur l'article 44 qui qui précise dans la
loi de 1905 le préfet pourra prononcer
la fermeture administrative temporaire
des lieux de culte dans lesquels des
propos haineux sont venus écouter un tel
dispositif existe déjà depuis la loi
sylt de 2017 et il est inscrit au livre
2 du code de la sécurité intérieure dès
lors lancer l'introduction ces nouvelles
dispositions dans la loi est du 9
décembre 1905
plutôt que dans le code de la sécurité
intérieure interroge et mériterait
d'être justifié ce sont quelques
éléments sur l'affaiblissement des
libertés publiques qui affaiblissent
également les principes républicains eux
mêmes donc quel est l'intérêt d'aller
dans ce sens puisqu'on veut renforcer
les valeurs de la république
la sénatrice persie bien monsieur le
ministre mes amis je vous avez la parole
mais maintenant vos questions
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président de nombreuses questions ont
été posées je vais être exhaustif
évidemment avec madame la ministre
d'avoir peut-être dire on en propose
productifs est ce que savait pas grand
chose à voir avec le débat mais
j'entends le sénateur je regrette si
vous n'avez pas être invitée mais je
voudrais dire monsieur le sénateur que
c'est l'histoire de votre commune c'est
madame la maire de la commune qui ma
vérité il me semble qu'on sait que
j'aurais pu peut-être partager cela avec
les élus du département et surtout le
caserne départementale appartient aux
deux présentent deux départements et je
n'ai fait qu'inaugurer un lieu qui était
départemental en l'occurrence je
regrette donc que j'aurais peut-être dû
regarder que ni la mère ni la présente
département qui passerait de votre bord
politique vous avez invité je le ferai
la prochaine fois je m'en excuse
si vous en avez s'il n'avait pas été pas
été le cas
voilà j'en suis je suis confus et
j'imagine qu'il y avait quand même une
discussion locales sur les autres sujets
évidemment bon monsieur sur vous poser
finalement une question qui est assez
miroir à celle du président bas et je
vais essayer de répondre d'abord à la
philosophie générale du texte que dont
vous nous invitez indépendamment des
dispositions tout intéressante mais
évidemment qui naissent nous l'espérons
une analyse nous avons devant nous un
danger ce dont j'ai chacun le connaît
c'est le séparatisme islamistes en
général mais il peut y avoir d'autres
séparatistes vont pouvoir discuter
d'ailleurs à l'envi si vous le souhaitez
mais je ne veux pas confondre les deux
et c'est le plus important le plus
meurtrier est évidemment celui pour
lequel nous avons intérêt à prendre très
rapidement le réveil républicain dont
nous invite à la fois le président de la
république et si j'entends vos
interventions quasiment tout le monde
ici
mais nous souhaitons le faire dans le
cadre de l' équilibre des principes
républicains pour reprendre le titre du
texte notamment du fait que la loi de
1905 est pas qu elle derrière elle non
seulement 40 ans d'histoire laïc de
notre république et surmontent à
philippe le bel la volonté que la
religion soit une affaire de l'état et
non pas une affaire d' ingérence
étrangère puisque ce que nous cherchons
ici à faire c'est lutter seul contre le
séparatisme islamistes mais aussi contre
les ingérences étrangères qui ne sont
pas identiques
nous pouvons vouloir limiter l'influencé
de l'état turc de l'état algérien de
l'état tunisien de l'état marocain et
d'autres états parfois il était
anglo-saxon sur les communautés
protestantes par exemple sur le
territoire national sans penser un seul
instant que cette ingérence dont nous
pensons qu'elle est dangereuse pour la
république ne se confond pas non plus
avec l'islamisme radical ou le
séparatisme c'est ce que fait présent la
réplique notamment lorsqu'il a le
courage de mettre fin aux imams détacher
c'est non pas islamiste que d'envoyer un
fonctionnaire de l'état algérien ou
turcs sur le territoire national ils ne
sont pas islamistes mais ils ne sont pas
on va dire la loyauté absolue avec la
réplique française puisqu'ils sont
fonctionnaires de leur pays donc d'abord
il ya le séparatisme islamistes et de
manière générale le séparatisme et puis
il ya l contre les agences étrangères
premier point nous le faisons
conformément à la tradition donc que la
religion est une affaire française
quelle que soit cette religion c'est ce
qu'a voulu dire philippe le bel au pape
parce qu'il a voulu lever des impôts
notamment
c'est ce qu'on a fait me semble-t-il
aussi avec les juifs de france ce la
révolution c'est ce qu'on a refait après
le concordat grâce à la république et
c'est ce que nous disons aujourd'hui
pour les musulmans ils ont évidemment
toute liberté en tant que citoyen en
tant que croyants mais c'est une affaire
qui intéresse la république française
est pas un état étranger et nous le
faisons dans un cadre qui est celui de
la non reconnaissance de religion par
rapport à une autre
et lorsque vous me dites
le présent sueur lorsque vous dites que
ce président bah pourquoi embêter toutes
les autres religions mais qu'auriez vous
souhaitez que je fasse que je propose au
conseil des ministres un texte qui
concerne que des musulmans il aurait été
évidemment contraire aux lois de
séparation des églises et de l'état
alors peut-être que ça peut être une
solution politique
cette avance qu'on fait des pays qui
n'ont pas la laïcité française des
autrichiens aulnoye spécifiques
par contre l'islam mais contre les
islamistes dans lequel il part du
principe que l'islamisme politique étant
un dérivé de l'islam je crois qu'on peut
le constater et c'est pas une insulte
évidemment à le faire pour se dire que
si on veut faire le réveil républicain
sur veut éviter d'angélisme et par
ailleurs est fidèle à la république et
finalement l'histoire de france de
considérer que c'est une affaire
éminemment française que c'est de la
religion sans s'immiscer dans le culte
bien évidemment ou dans le dogme bien
sûr et que par ailleurs nous voulons
être fidèle à 1905 et à sa promesse
kenya la non reconnaissance par l'état
d'un culte plutôt qu'un autre
nous ne pouvons pas distinguer ces
cultes et donc je le dis bien sûr que ça
peut gêner bien sûr que je peux
comprendre les interrogations des cultes
mais il ne serions pas a faussement naïf
d'abord j'aurais été heureux et
l'archevêque de reims sans doute aussi
de savoir quand même ça puisque ce site
et dans dans la commission vous même
monsieur présents sur le site et le
culte protestant ou parfois même ici
j'ai entendu à l'assemblée comme ici des
cultes catholiques
enfin les catholiques ont jamais été
favorable en 1905 à la n205 chacun le
sait aujourd'hui je comprends que c'est
une loi d' équilibre pour lequel et se
sont inscrits et pour lequel l'
équilibre a été trouvé
enfin on va pas me faire croire non plus
que les cultes heureux en 1905 ont tous
soutenu les parlementaires de la nation
et la république à voter absolument la
séparation des églises et de l'état
chacun sait que c'est pas comme ça que
ça s'est passé ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas faire attention aux
interrogations et aux inquiétudes et
nous sommes là pour les rassurer je
compte évidemment sur le sénat comme sur
l'assemblée nationale pour corriger un
certain nombre de choses et j'ai déjà
fait beaucoup de compromis par rapport
au premier texte après le conseil d'état
ensuite après discussion avec les cultes
et je les reverrai évidemment avant la
séance publique du sénat je pourrais
modifié d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
dix
si on encore sur votre demande mais on
pourra en discuter d'ailleurs sur les
dispositions nous avons déjà modifié
mais oui nous assumons le fait que la
loi des général elle s'adresse à tous
les cultes et j'aurais d'ailleurs dire
que les dérives sectaires dont madame
ministre s'occuper et elle évoque
souvent ce sujet sont souvent aussi dans
l'entrée du culte puisque nous ne
reconnaissons aucun culte et que nous
devons faire attention à ne pas nous
focaliser sur des cultes que nous
connaissons et méprisés ou ne pas voir
les cultes que nous ne connaissons pas
parce qu'ils ne sont pas aussi organiser
aussi historiquement implantée sur le
territoire national donc voilà monsieur
le président bah on est on essaye
peut-être peut-être pas avec la plus
grande efficacité selon vous mais on
essaye de se doter d'armes très forte
très dur et d'être dans le cadre de 1905
et je veux dire aux sénateurs le relier
que mais je peux leur répondre et il
verra sans doute mais les mains pour ce
jeu que que la loi la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle devrait rien réglé
dans cette matière puisque nous sommes
bien d'accord sur le fait que personne
ne peut se prévaloir ni de son origine
de sa religion pour avoir une demande
est l'exception de la règle commune
vous le faites par l'intermédiaire de
mon constitutionnel je ne pense pas
qu'ils moi personnellement je ne pense
pas que ce soit nécessaire
en tout cas pas avec le texte présenté
par la majorité sénatoriale même si je
peux entendre le débat
nous pensons nous qu'effectivement c'est
ce que nous essaierons de faire
notamment dans son article 4 notamment
son article 18
que personne ne peut se prévaloir leçons
de cette communauté je mets des
guillemets pour imposer telle ou telle
expression parce que je veux dire à
monsieur sueur également vous répondant
que l'assassinât de monsieur pâtit
évidemment je ne sais pas s'il aurait
été évitée avec un texte de loi ce
serait bien prétentieux que le dire mais
il a manqué deux choses mises à
l'intérieur à coup sûr pour éviter que
ce matin ce soir ou demain matin cela
recommence parce que c'est quoi le
mimétisme de l'assassinât monsieur pâtit
c'est un homme monsieur nina qui vient
avec un autre faire pression sur
l'éducation nationale notamment la
principale de collège rentrant dans le
collège disant qu'est ce que c'est que
ce voyou je mets des guillemets qui a
voulu imposer un cours sur la liberté
d'expression
je lui a taillé le faire et si ça
continue vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir et que de l'autre côté
mejdina sur la vidéo qu'il avoue
lui-même posté en ligne
il lance une fatwa numérique puisqu'il
considère que ce personnage qu'il cite
en l'occurrence monsieur pâtit était le
responsable d'ailleurs en mentant mais
c'est un autre sujet et a donc donné
l'idée aux terroristes
le vrai celui qui avait le couteau si je
veux dire de pouvoir passer à l'acte
puisque avait ce qu'on appelle bah voilà
un assassinat a lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais aujourd'hui monsieur sueur je ne
peux toujours pas même si j'ai des notes
des rationnements territoriaux comme
c'était le cas de la préfecture des
yvelines
quand je vois sur une note en
l'occurrence quand le chef d rt voix sur
une note qu' il ya une pression
communautaire pour voir principal de
collège il n'y a pas de délit pour
empêcher le faire il n'y a pas un délit
pour empêcher une femme d'être qui veut
pas être soigné par un homme et qui la
menace il n'y a pas de délit pour que
quelqu'un qui vient le fuit à l'accueil
d'une mairie et qui refuse de parler
avec moins de femmes puissent être
poursuivis nathalie de loi nous permet
aujourd'hui de pouvoir faire ce délit de
séparatisme donc ça recommencerait
l'enchaînement monsieur chenilles à avec
la principale du collège
jusqu'à présent je ne peux pas
intervenir et deuxièmement il y aurait
cette fatwa numérique qui est bien plus
sibylline plus compliqué qu'une appel au
meurtre
nous ne pourrions pas ce n'est pas
l'article 18 pour répondre à même de la
gontrie qui n'a rien à voir à 4,24 les
j'aurai l'occasion d'en discuter en
quelques instants le condamné et le
faire retirer des réseaux sociaux est
donc en tout cas l'enchaînement
diabolique de la pression communautaire
dont nous répondons par des dites
séparatisme et de la fatwa en ligne pour
nous répondons par atik 18 permet au
moins pour larmes administratif
d'intervenir et se faire retirer le
contenu en ligne et poursuivre ce
chemin-là soit poursuivre monsieur nina
quand on sait qu'il est allé faire
pression communautaire séparatistes
envers le principal de collège
je voudrais dire donc en même temps à
monsieur le présent sûr que si monsieur
président de la commission des lois le
permet je prêt exactement classement
national nous faire parvenir le tableau
comparatif
avant après 1900 à 1950 si monsieur prix
vous l'avez déjà fait distribuer je vous
en remercie et vous constaterez qu
effectivement il y aura bien des
intérêts dans 1905 demain par rapport
aux difficultés d'aujourd'hui
moi je vous le redis monsieur le
président c'était très fidèle à la loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
de dire qu'il ya eu lieu cultuel qui
doit être gérée comme telle et cas des
lieux culturels et que c'est pas une
chose que de gérer la mosquée où le
temple protestant de tourcoing que
l'amicale de boules du quai du halot qui
est très sympathique je recommande
mais c'est pas tout à fait le même type
d'association est d'ailleurs rarement
financé par des états étrangers
d'ailleurs le club et le club de boules
du quai du halot et jusqu'à présent les
déductions fiscales
les financements étrangers la propriété
la taxation la comptabilité n'était pas
la même imposition 1905 à 1911 et nous
aurions dû faire ce travail les
protestants l'ont fait ils sont allés
1905 quasi intégralité les nos amis
musulmans doivent pouvoir le faire pour
gérer leurs lieux de culte ça les
protège en même temps que ça permet à
l'état de pouvoir avoir un oeil et c'est
bien normal sur l'ordre public health il
ne s'agit pas de s'immiscer dans le
culte alors vous évoquez les immeubles
de rapport
je répondrai donc assis à monsieur le
sénateur en même temps que vous monsieur
le président aujourd'hui nous voulons
être fidèle à 1905 c'est à dire que nous
ne voulons pas subventionner les cultes
devrait constater devant vous qui ne
s'agit pas là d'un principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la république
ce qui a été constitutionnalisées c'est
la non reconnaissance particulière mais
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas de
décision constitutionnelle disons que ce
serait supra législatif que de ne pas
subventionner les cultes
c'est tellement vrai que d'une part
l'alsace moselle plus ces départements
vers les territoires pardon pacifique
plus à certains autres territoires
ultramarins dans la guyane permet vous
savez des financements de ministres du
culte mais la déduction fiscale
c'est une forme de financement du culte
public sans aucun doute le bail
emphytéotique
sans aucun doute c'est une forme des de
la propriété des personnes publiques
donc aujourd'hui peut-être que le
conseil qu'au 6 l
va tirer de notre texte un principe qui
fera les belles heures de jurisprudence
administrative
mais ce qui est constitutionnalisée
c'est la non reconnaissance sanaa et si
t'es pas le nom subventionnement il
appartient au parlement de savoir s'il
doit pas changer ce texte le
gouvernement ne le souhaite pas m'enfin
c'est pour l'instant législatif et pas
autre chose que législatif comme dirait
c'est déjà beaucoup mais ce n'est pas le
bloc de constitutionnalité mais nous ne
voulons pas donc subventionner les
cultes
après tout nous pourrions prendre les
dispositions qui est conforme à celle de
la république au début du 20e siècle
qu'a fait la république elle a
nationalisé les biens d'église
peut-être qu'il faudrait nationaliser
les biens des musulmans pour être
s'assurer de l'équité et que c'est sûr
que ce soit très patriote et très
français puisque nous serions
propriétaires par les communes imaginons
les lieux de culte musulmans comme on
est propriétaire des églises dans 90%
des cas ce n'est pas la solution non
plus de nous en proposer
elle n'est pourtant pas si tu as de
cette solution mais elle est
médiatiquement et politiquement avoué le
compliqué c'était quoi c'était une
spoliation des biens d'église jadis et
pour des raisons que chacun connaît et
qui a fait naître beaucoup de
difficultés pour ne pas dire plus dans
la république
mais si on ne veut pas subventionner les
cultes monsieur sûr si on part du
principe que nos compatriotes notamment
musulmans n'ont pas les avantages qu'ont
notamment les chrétiens et
singulièrement les catholiques de ne pas
avoir rénové leur église puisque c'est
les communes qui le font et que d'autre
part nous ne voulons pas qu'ils soient
financés par les étrangers puisque nous
avons des dispositions qui prévoient
notamment de connaître les financements
étrangers s'y opposer expliquez-moi
comment les cultes se finance ni
subvention n'étant pas sa taille tant la
république avant 1905 les propriétés
n'appartiennent pas donc aux communes
contrairement à 90% des collectivités
j'imagine que dans votre belle ville
monsieur le président entretenir pour
les catholiques la cathédrale ce serait
un peu de frais avouons le et que
d'autre part nous ne voulons pas qu'il
soit financé ni par le qatar l'arabie
saoudite l'algérie je ne sais quel autre
état ou quelle autre organisation
il faut bien trouver des sources de
financement qui sont conformes à l'idée
de laïcité c'est pas la puissance
publique qui aide et à l'idée du
patriotisme c'est pas les ingérences
étrangères qui décide et donc nous avons
comme idée de revenir à ce qui existait
avant la loi mon et c'était très bien
dit par monsieur le sénateur permis
pour d'autres associations les
associations de 1901 et c'est d'ailleurs
un peu à une contradiction de votre
raisonnement si vous le permettez
puisque ces permis dans 1900 c'est pas
permis en 1905
donc voyez on encourage les gens restent
en 1900 puisque là ils ont droit d'avoir
des immeubles de rapport
en 1905 et une forme associative
particulière il n'y en a pas le droit
et nous disons que les fidèles ont le
droit dans un cadre limité vous avez vu
que le parlement notamment l'assemblée
nationale a souhaité qu'à paix pour
éviter les empires financiers seul à
avoir des immeubles de rapport
et je veux dire aux sénateurs que moi je
me pose la question sur les onéreux
ce n'a pas été l'arbitrage fait par
l'assemblée nationale mais nous pouvons
être ouverts à une discussion comme
celle ci sans doute que ce sera
difficile de trouver un compromis entre
les deux chambres
je ne sais même pas si la majorité
sénatoriale de son star serait d'accord
avec vous mais la question se pose avec
les cultes qui demandent les immeubles
de rapport notamment nos compatriotes
musulmans mais pas que ils demandent
aussi des déductions fiscales plus
importantes voire même des crédits
d'impôts ce sont des façons de
subventionner le culte qui ne sont pas
directs et indirects en tout cas
l'immeuble de rapports il ya une chance
incroyable ces pluies il n'est pas
innocent à subventionnement déguisé il
s'agit viennent quelque chose de
totalement privée qui n'a rien à voir la
puissance publique et qui est moins
hypocrite que le bail emphytéotique est
moins hypocrite que la déduction fiscale
je rajouterais à cet argument que
souvent les croyants du culte musulmans
et catholiques qui ce n'est pas un jour
que le faire c'est une population qui
plus que la moyenne des français ne
payent pas d'impôts par ailleurs et ne
peuvent donc pas déduire de leurs impôts
et donc qu'ils font parfois très
généraux à leur église
c'est donc une question intéressante que
de voir comment financer un culte sans
que ce soit la puissance publique sans
sur la puissance étrangère
nous n'avons trouvé que les immeubles de
rapport mais nous sommes évidemment
prêts à de nouvelles à de nouvelles
idées
monsieur le député le sénateur webb led
ajustement et
et avec justesse d'ailleurs posé la
question l'instruction à domicile etc
est une question compliquée mais
fondamentale il permettra de faire une
réponse évasive puisqu'il appartient
l'éducation nationale doit vous apporter
la réponse able to complete
singulièrement parce qu'il a été
auditionné me semble-t-il par la
commission des affaires culturelles et
que le sénat n'a pas fait le choix de la
commission spéciale mais je respecte
évidemment évidemment le choix
parlementaire qui a été fait ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que lorsque je
reviens de marseille et que je parle
même pas de notre département vous le
connaissez mieux voire beaucoup mieux
que moi
mais qu'ont expliqué je veux donner les
chiffres exacts qui m'a été donnée par
le recteur de l'académie de marseille
je ne vais pas tarder à vous les donner
comme dirait coluche et qu'on passe de
quatre cents à mille trois cent
cinquante enfants en un an qui ne sont
pas d'indication nationale on peut
penser qu'ils ne sont évidemment pas
tous sous une coupe islamistes ou
sectaire bien sûr on sait tous qui a une
grande partie d'entre eux qui sont au
courant des maladies ont 50% dit la
statistique éducation nationale qu'une
partie d'entre eux d'ailleurs vive
d'instruction à domicile avec des
parents qui leur apporte évidemment
l'éducation qu'il faut et notamment
structure domicile
mais quand un parti quand même notamment
cinq gérants des petites filles qui sont
retirés de la république et que l'idée
des séparatistes c'est de créer une
communauté de la naissance à la mort qui
n'a rien à voir avec la république et
donc c'est une question très importante
et j'ai remarqué que vous ne l'avez vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas repousser
vous avez vu je demande et la question
des moyens
ce n'est pas la mairie qui doivent le
faire je voudrais vous rassurer sur ce
point est de mise et question l'a dit à
l'assemblée nous vous redire à son hôte
au sénat et deuxièmement c'est évident
la question des contrôles
il s'agit là de rentrée lors d'un grand
débat autorisation déclaration bref de
mieux connaître quand j'étais maire
comme vous monsieur le maire
je n'ai pas eu moi toujours les moyens
de connaître le nombre de petit enfant
qui étaient dans ma ville il n'y a pas
de fichier des habitants d'une ville
l'affiché électorale il ya des enfants
qui s'inscrivent à l'école publique
s'inscrivent avec au privé ce contrat il
ya un fichier la caf est affichée dacp m
mais à part affiché globale des
habitants de la commune et donc à ce
titre le maire kechach et la
scolarisation des enfants dans l'école
élémentaire n'a pas les moyens de ses
contrôles et une question non plus donc
je crois que c'est une question très
importante mais fermé au musée national
de porter cet argument
madame larbi a évoqué la question de
l'objectif européen notamment dans la
haine en ligne à la raison oui nous
avons ce travail à faire je pense qu'on
en prendra avec monsieur ou et monsieur
dupont moretti sur la haine en ligne se
serait notamment madame la ministre tête
d'évoquer ce qu'elle fait avec pharos
qu'il ya beaucoup été renforcée madame
de la gontrie évoqué la différence je
rendrai pas sur notre remarque
précédente vous avez parfaitement raison
de la la ça triste de constater que tout
n'est pas dans le texte comme vous
l'avez remarqué j'avais déjà évoqué je
sais mais sans doute avoir un texte plus
large mais mais il met sa intérieures
portent les dispositions qui auraient du
ministère de l'intérieur
mais je suis comme vous convaincu ayant
été maire que l'urbanisme a un rôle
considérable petit du logement de
peuplement comme on dit un rôle
considérable qu évidemment les questions
éducatives honda rôle considérable que
questions d'immigration et d'intégration
ont un rôle considérable et que comme
dirait le proverbe africain il faut tout
un village pour faire un enfant il faut
sans doute toute une politique publique
pour pour améliorer les la puissance
publique afin d'éviter le
le communautarisme qui même au
séparatisme vous avez bien raison mais
chacun apporte sa pierre à l'édifice je
voudrais ont souligné la différence
profonde 98 24
l'article 24 c les opérations de police
l'article 18 c'est les fonctionnaires en
tant qu'agent lorsqu'ils sont mis en
accusation personnel notamment dans le
cadre familial ce n'est pas l'article 24
donc on a vraiment affaire je n'ai pas
vu l'écriture exact proposées par
monsieur daubresse me semble-t-il ce
matin mais si j'ai bien compris des
rapports que j'ai pu avoir républicain
est que monsieur le sénateur on a bien
rester dans cette philosophie mais
peut-être que je préside la commission
pourrait mieux que moi précisé ce qui a
été adopté ce matin me semble-t-il mais
il s'agit bien de deux articles
différents dans leur fondement
madame boyer je vais laisser madame la
ministre répondre à votre question parce
que ces articles
je vais vous faire deux remarques la
première c'est que si vous avez écrit il
sans cesse au préfet pour avoir des
nouvelles de vos mariages et que nous a
pas répondu c'est normal ça avait écrit
au procureur
puisqu'on m'a dit monsieur le sénateur
c'est le procureur qui a une
responsabilité des mariages et pas le
préfet puisque vous agissez madame en
tant que officier sur le plan du
ministre de la justice ce que vous
marier les gens et deuxièmement madame
vous savez je reviens de marseille et je
suis très étonné de ce que j'ai vu dans
certains secteurs delà de la mairie
et quand je vois notamment qu' il y a un
local public
ça te ne sera pas de la majorité
actuelle je voudrais préciser alors je
me suis entretenu avec le thunder de
marseille les yeux dans les yeux comme
on dit et il a été très attentif et je
l'en remercie
et nous espérons des décisions qu'un
local public à un contrat de bail avec
une association sportive et qui est un
sous bail qui est fait par cette
association sportive pour un lieu de
culte qui lui est très clairement
soupçonné plus que ça de radicalisation
et que les services des renseignements
territoriaux que la dgsi et que les
services de police
après de multiples alertes à la mairie
de secteur voit que le bail n'a pas été
résilié
je m'inquiète parfois des discours
nationaux et de la vie locale
pour tout vous dire et je suis tout à
fait prêt à parler avec vous si vous
souhaitez être faite de police
j'imagine aussi donc faute chose qu'il
faut faire attention aux attaques à
2000m
surtout lorsque vous attaquez ça fait
trois fois madame la sénatrice que vous
le faites dans trois commissions
différentes
je me permets de vous dire que sur ce
point je suis prêt effectivement à
regarder qui a les actes qui
correspondent à leur parole vous avez
évoqué je crois monsieur le sénateur la
différence entre le sauvegarde à l'ordre
public et l'ordre public
si j'ai bien compris la question qui
m'étaient posées ça revenait pas
notamment du lieu de culte mais ça
relevait de l'association art et bien ça
votre question c'était pour le préfet en
lien avec le lieu de culte
c'était cette question là merci monsieur
le ministre le lorsque le préfet
reconnaît enfin le préfet a deux mois
pour s'opposer à la reconnaissance du
caractère cultuel d'une association qui
a été déclaré qu'ils aient tous les cinq
ans et il peut s'opposer à la
reconnaissance pour trois motifs dont un
motif d'ordre public et je trouve ça un
peu subjectif
j'entends donc c'est pas sûr
l'association mécène sur le culte donc
c'est une lors nous mettons ce que fait
déjà la jurisprudence l'ordre public
vous le savez une personne c'est une
vieille tradition de jurisprudence
administrative
il s'agit pas il faudrait aussi à
préciser madame benbassa que de dire ce
qu'est ou para culte c'est pas du tout
l'objet vous savez qu'aujourd'hui un
rescrit c'est la mode d'actuels c'est à
dire que il ya un rescrit préfectoral
qui est fait un rescrit du ministère
intérieur pour reconnaître la qualité
cultuelle non pas en tant que culte on a
pas à dire ce qu'est un culte et je
comprends votre question sa subjectivité
mais en tant que critère qui correspond
à ce que doit être au centre droit
administratif du terme la qualité
culturelle qui permet notamment de faire
des déductions fiscales de ne pas payer
d'impôt local etc etc au sens
administratif je dis vraiment aussi
problème la sénatrice qui est en visio
avec nous c'est pas le préfet qui jugent
du culte de ce que doit être un but et
nous pensons nous que la jurisprudence
administrative doit désormais être
légalisés et que les troubles profonds à
l'ordre public par exemple des ministres
du culte qui répèterai un certain nombre
de dispositifs de discours qui serait de
relative à la haine ou si je reprends
l'exemple qui a été fait tout à l'heure
par madame la sénatrice en disant mais
vous pouvez déjà condamner des personnes
individuellement sans condamner des
collectivités ou des lieux
aujourd'hui c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un était condamnée plusieurs fois
par la justice judiciaire que nous
pouvons en tirer la conclusion qu'il
faut fermer le lieu de culte dissoudre
l'association
c'est d'ailleurs de notre problème est
un problème très important notamment
lorsqu'on veut mettre fin les gens dit
séparatiste donc il ne nous a pas semblé
qu'il s'agissait là de subjectivité mais
bien d'appliquer la jurisprudence
administrative et que nous la retenions
plus objective puisque nous la mettons
dans la loi mais on pourra en discuter
largement si vous souhaitez dans
l'hémicycle pour pouvoir préciser parce
qu'évidemment nous sommes vous comme
nous comme vous très attaché à la
liberté de culte
j'en terminerai peut-être parce que je
crois avoir répondu à toutes les
questions et notamment je voudrais dire
à monsieur bart pour en terminer par là
que l'une des difficultés que nous avons
c'est que les les islamistes nous
semble-t-il sont minoritaires dans le
pays
bien sûr mais qu'ils ont fait nos pea
médiatique dans le discours sur internet
à coup sûr suffit de refaire
si vous étiez un jeune musulman et vous
cherchez comment faire la prière donc
est ce qu est-ce qui est relève des
prescriptions religieuses vous y verriez
99 et encore je suis je suis je suis je
suis pas large
99 % de contenu salafistes ou des frères
musulmans c'est à dire des choses que
nous voulons que matt donc vous avez
tout à fait raison de ce sénateur je
partage votre avis le salafisme ou les
frères musulmans ils sont parfois aussi
en dehors des lieux de culte qui sont
surtout en dehors de notre culte dans
les associations dans les réunions
publiques parfois dans le prisme
politique parfois souvent sur internet
etc
je ne peux pas vous donner tort sur ce
point est-ce qu'on chasserait les
salafistes avec nos dispositions des
lieux de culte pour les emmener vers le
champ politique le champ sociétal ch
sociale peut-être j'allais dire qu'ils y
sont déjà vous me faites compléter les
phrases même des rapporteurs
c'est déjà pas si mal que d'assurer au
lieu de culte musulman
la garantie que ceux qui sont ouverts
sur le lieu de la république sont
conformes aux principes et aux valeurs
de la république qui complète tout à
fait musulmans fréquentant la mosquée
sans pour autant être qualifié
d'islamiste parce qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer aussi la grande
susceptibilité pour ne pas dire parfois
la grande blessure des musulmans qui
sont confondus par leur part leur
religion en d'autres choses qui ne sont
évidemment pas et personne ici une
le conte fait recette cette confusion
est par ailleurs on peut être rigoriste
dans sa religion sans être contraire aux
valeurs de la république
moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui donnent
un jugement selon qu'on pratique ou pas
de religion avec carte degré de pratique
je pense que ce ne serait pas convenable
je peux avoir mon opinion mais ça n'a
pas d'intérêt dans la loi bien
évidemment c'est pour cela que les
dispositions que nous proposons il y en
a beaucoup qui concerne le champ
associatif et je ferai remarquer
monsieur le président bas que ces
dispositions notamment qui vise à
suspendre dissoudre l'association sont
dispositions extrêmement nouvelle
nous espérons tous qu'elle soit validée
par le juge constitutionnel et madame la
ministre
le contrat d'engagement républicain est
également extrêmement fort mettons fin à
des sans doute centaines de milliers
oserais-je dire des millions d'euros
qu'elle soit versée par les
collectivités locales les organismes hlm
les le pôle emploi la ceppm la caf
j'ai mis fin à des subventions de la caf
pour des voyages 100% annales
ça existe dans notre pays pour plein de
raisons parce que nous il y avait sans
doute une volonté peut-être de ne pas
mettre de la politique publique partout
et je pense qu'il faut le faire parce
que cet argent public et bien de lutter
dans le champ associatif
en plus du culte pour éviter évidemment
la propagation du salafisme des frères
musulmans
ça me paraît évidemment important je
pense que votre question est évidemment
très bonne et je crois que nous avons
des réponses très forte dans les
limitations du droit d'association nous
l'espérons confirmée par le juge
constitution merci monsieur et madame la
ministre monsieur président oui assez
rapidement à 6 personnes niveau
d'inconvénients je veux faire des
réponses groupe et synthétique parce que
le temps qui nous est imparti je crois
avance mais je suis évidemment la
disposition de chaque sénatrice ou
sénateurs qui auraient besoin d'avoir
des éléments complémentaires d'ici la
suite de nos débats peut-être d'abord
sur la question de la lutte contre le
cyber islamisme qui a été évoquée je
voudrais vous dire comme l'a dit à
monsieur mise l'intérieur que nous avons
considérablement renforcé les moyens de
pharos d'ailleurs au lendemain de
l'assassinât et de l'attentât terroriste
contre le professeur samuel pâtit je me
suis rendu chez pharos pour faire un
retour d'expérience et constater le
travail qui a été mené et c'est suite à
cela que nous avons décidé avec le
ministre de l'intérieur d'élargir les
horaires d'ouverture de faro c'est de
faire en sorte
de prendre l'engagement que 24 heures
sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 les activités de
faro soit véritablement réactif c'est
chose faite nous y avons affiliés de
nouveaux policiers et gendarmes et je
les remercie d'ailleurs pour ce travail
parce que c'est un travail
extraordinairement difficile que d'être
confronté continuellement à longueur de
journée à des contenus terroristes ou
d'ailleurs à des contenus pédo criminel
puisque c'est aussi ce qui est traité
par les services de pharos je voudrais
vous dire que les propos d' apologie du
terrorisme sont par exemple
systématiquement poursuivis
il ya maintenant à des signalements qui
existent par ailleurs nous avons
réactivé ce qui s'appelle le groupe
permanent de contacts au ministère de
l'intérieur qui avait été créée par
bernard cazeneuve à l'époque et qui nous
permet de réunir plusieurs fois par mois
au ministère de l'intérieur les
directions des du ministère de
l'intérieur avec pharos mais avec les
directions des réseaux sociaux parce que
nous sommes aperçus que parfois les
réseaux sociaux étaient longs dans leur
réponse voire se permettait de répondre
aux services de l'état qu'il ne
souhaitait pas apporter l'identification
de telle ou telle personne contrairement
à ce qui était demandé par fars ozon ça
nous semblait important de réactiver ce
dialogue est dorénavant c'est chose
faite
nous partageons d'ailleurs les chiffres
des signalements de pharos lors des
points presse mensuelle que nous faisons
pour formellement aux souhaits de
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
chaque mois il nous arrive de partager
justement régulièrement les signalements
qui sont faits via pharos afin que
chacun puisse suivre l'activité qui est
évidemment en croissance parce que les
citoyens connaissent de mieux en mieux
le dispositif de pharos nous avons par
ailleurs développer la mise à
disposition d'officiers de liaison dans
des associations qui mènent un travail
similaire je pense par exemple à point
de contact nous avons pour la première
fois déléguer un officier de la
gendarmerie nationale et je remercie la
gendarmerie nationale pour cela dans
l'association afin de fluidifier la
possibilité de faire des signalements
qui existent sur les réseaux sociaux via
cette association et c'est absolument
fondamental parce qu'on observe et cela
a été dit à de nombreuses reprises mais
je crois que c'est vraiment important
pour pour permettre à chacun de
comprendre
l'évolution de ces phénomènes on observe
que par exemple les jeunes qui se sont
radicalisées ne se sont pas radicaliser
dans la rue où en est en contact et à la
sortie d'une mosquée mais devant leur
écran et parfois tout seuls dans leur
chambre devant leur écran de téléphone
donc ça doit véritablement nous
préoccuper c'est pour ça que nous avons
plus de moyens sur faro c'est la lutte
contre le cyber islamisme et c'est pour
ça aussi que nous avons créée
conformément à la volonté du président
de la république une unité de
contre-discours républicain au sein du
sehy pdr au ministère de l'intérieur
afin d'apporter des réponses notamment
aux fausses informations qui peuvent
avoir lieu et on voit à quel point c'est
nécessaire notamment suite aux actions
pour dissoudre des groupes comme l'a
fait à mes sioniste de l'intérieur je
pense à la dissolution du collectif
cheikh yacine ou baraka city ou du ccf
londonien à défaut d'informations sur
les réseaux sociaux
il a été important de pouvoir y apporter
des réponses et rétablir simplement
l'effet de l'action qui est menée en ce
qui concerne la question des mariages
particulièrement des mariages forcés qui
ont été abordés par plusieurs d'entre
vous et notamment par la sénatrice
valérie boyer faut dire que oui nous
avons des chiffres dans le monde nous
savons que c'est environ 12 millions
jeunes filles qui sont mariées de force
et nous savons d'après les chiffres de
l' ong plan international ou de l'eau et
joggers note braille notamment qu'une
jeune fille de une jeune fille sur cinq
pardon dans le monde est mariée de force
avant ses 18 ans et la france n'échappe
pas à ce phénomène puisque les
différentes estimations qui ont été
réalisés par le gamme ce qui est une
fédération d'associations qui protège
les femmes notamment les femmes
migrantes par l'ined ou d'autres nous
disent qu environ il y aurait deux cent
mille femmes mariées de force en france
à l'heure actuelle je rappelle que c'est
bas par an je le dis parce que il ya des
confusions dans certains chiffres qui
ont été donnés donc pour être clair dans
les chiffres que je partage avec vous on
estime qu'il y à deux cent mille femmes
à l'heure actuelle si je peux le dire de
cette manière très vilaine et grossière
dans les dossiers de stocks entre
guillemets de mariage qui existe il y a
deux cent mille femmes c'est une
estimation basse il ya beaucoup
d'associations en france qui estime que
cette que ce chiffre il est bas et que
du fait de certains
certaines situations notamment le fait
que ce chiffre n'intègre pas par exemple
est demandeuse d'asile où les réfugiés
et bien certaines associations estiment
qu'en fait il y en aurait en réalité
beaucoup plus
moi je partage les élèves qui ont été
relayés ici du fait qu'à l'heure
actuelle il est très difficile pour les
élus et pour les mères d'agir et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que nous avons
décidé en écoutant les élus locaux que
nous avons décidé d'amplifier les
dispositifs qui existent
je voudrais vous dire également que le
nom d' appels au 39 19 pour des mariages
forcés
il est passé de environ 50 appels en
2010 est à près de 60 appels en 2018
c'est sûr qu'il ya une légère évolution
allez après année pour 2019 c'est la
même chose pour la question des mariages
divorcés
lorsque l'on observe comme pour le
certificat de virginité c'est que très
régulièrement les alertes que nous avons
elles émanent des ong qui accompagnent
ces jeunes filles et qui ont été alertés
par la jeune fille ou par des copines
par l'école etc
du fait que ce mariage allait survenir
et donc nous nous avons voulu renforcer
le fait que ces ong puissent alerter et
puis c'est fait et que l'officier d'état
civil puisse donc vérifier l'existence
du consentement qui soit exprimée de
façon de façon très libre par par les
futurs époux donc notre réponse est ce
que nous portons dans ce projet de loi
c'est que le nôtre objectif principal
c'est de renforcer justement le
dispositif de lutte
a priori il était évoquée par plusieurs
d'entre vous mesdames et sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs la possibilité
de mieux sanctionner les mariages forcés
je l'entends nous avons voulu vraiment
pouvoir empêcher ces mariages de
survenir et donc notre volonté c'est de
pouvoir garantir vraiment cette liberté
matrimoniale entre les futurs époux et
notamment évidemment celle des femmes
même si je n'ignore pas que dans le cas
de très jeunes personnes il peut savoir
des garçons aussi qu'ils soient forcés à
cela mais l'immense majorité sont quand
même des femmes et des jeunes filles
donc notre article 17 il renforce le
dispositif de protection du consentement
des futurs époux lors de cette
célébration d'expression du consentement
aussi puisque ces dispositions elle
impose à l'officier d'état civil de
pouvoir s'entretenir séparément avec les
futurs époux dès lors qu'il y à un
signalement ou dès lors qu'il existe un
doute sur le caractère libre du
consentement après
l'audition commune et après l'examen des
pièces qui sont apportées et qui sont à
fournir à chaque fois en outre dans cet
article il y aura l'obligation faite à
l'officier d'état civil de saisir le
procureur de la république à des fins
d'éventuelles oppositions à un mariage
s'il conserve des doutes à l'issue de
l'entretien
je voudrais dire que je ne balaye pas
les questions qui ont été posées par
certains d'entre vous notamment sur la
formation des procureurs c'est un
travail que nous sommes en train de
mener avec le garde des sceaux parce
qu'effectivement une fois que cette loi
est votée il faut que à la fois les élus
mais aussi les procureurs puis s'en
emparer une demande qui nous a été faite
également par l'association des maires
de france quand nous les avons reçus
avec messieurs mise de l'intérieur et
donc nous sommes d'ores et déjà en train
de travailler
un guide nous avons confié la
coréalisation à la fédération du gard
qui permet de recenser les nouveaux
droits qui existeront pour les femmes et
notamment pour des migrants en tout des
primes war in vente afin qu'elles
puissent bénéficier de tous leurs droits
ce guide il sera traduit dans plusieurs
langues avec l'association women to
women et nous adresserons un guide
pratique aux élus je pense notamment aux
au maire et aux élus d'ailleurs pas
uniquement les maires qui sont dans des
petites communes qui n'ont pas forcément
de l'administration tout pas forcément
possibilité de se faire accompagner et
grâce à ce guide nous espérons qu'ils
pourront comme nous l'avons fait avec
les forces de l'ordre avec la grille
d'évaluation du danger avoir un guide de
questionnaires et pouvoir mener cet
entretien et pouvoir accéder librement
au consentement donc avec cette loi je
rappelle que lorsqu'il ya un doute sur
le caractère libre
l'officier va s'entretenir à ce sera une
obligation séparément avec les futurs
époux et dès lors que les doutes
subsistent il va obligatoirement saisir
le procureur de la république qui sera
formé et alerter aux fins d'éventuels
opposition au mariage qui nous permettra
de marquer une vraie différence avec ce
qui se passe actuellement
parce que c'est vrai que je dois dire
que plusieurs élus nous ont dit que
lorsqu'il avait dû alerter le procureur
et d'un soin il n'avait pas de réponse
soit il n'y avait pas de faits
suffisants là ce ne sera plus le non
consentement ne sera plus à prouver
celle inverse le consentement qui sera
approuvée je rappelle que c'est dès lors
qu'il y ait un doute ça ne va pas
s'appliquer à l'ensemble des mariages ça
va de soi mais je préfère le rappeler
parce qu'on a eu des questions à cet
égard il s'agit pas d'aller à chaque
mariage vérifier le consentement
il s'agit aussi de faire confiance aux
élus et au discernement de l'officier
d'état civil
qui mènent ces entretiens j'espère avoir
répondu comme je le disais précédemment
s'il ya d'autres questions des demandes
de précisions je suis évidemment avec
mon cabinet votre entière disposition
merci madame la miss alors mesdames les
rapporteurs me redemande quelques
instants de questions madame v rien puis
madame monsieur une question très rapide
monsieur le ministre les associations
catholiques sont des associations
diocésaines qui ont été jugés conformes
à 1905 mais qui ne sont pas des
associations 1905
du coup logiquement ce texte enfin ma
question c'est ce texte
s'applique-t-elle s'applique-t-il à elle
par exemple les immeubles de rapport est
ce que c'est une chose auquel elles
pourront avoir accès mais par contre les
contraintes et notamment sur la forme de
l'association qui les gère doivent-elles
changer afin de l'association de césène
pour se rendre conforme à la haute ex
telle qu'on l'écrit voilà même si leur
union
c'est peut-être avait juste c'est plutôt
une forme d'interrogation pour l'avenir
parce que ce texte bon on est
effectivement souvent nombreux à penser
qu'il faut faire des choses qu'il faut
écrire des choses mais ne pensez vous
pas qu'il faille aller plus loin d'une
manière plus générale on sait que dans
des quartiers c'est plus difficile que
d'autres bernard hoegy appelle les
écosystèmes qui se sont construits qui
se sont enfermés ne pensez vous pas
qu'une des clés aussi d'une des clés
importante c'est de réfléchir sur la
politique de peuplement des quartiers
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais travaillé là
dessus
y compris dans le cas de la politique de
la ville il faut obligatoirement se
l'avouer collectivement parce que voilà
petit de la ville n'a pas d'hier moi
j'ai travaillé sur toutes les politiques
de la ville depuis le début elles datent
pas d'hier nous n'avons jamais travaillé
sur les petits de peuplement pourquoi
parce qu'on parle de politique de
repeuplement aujourd'hui uniquement par
le levier des ressources
donc arrêtons arrêtons l'hypocrisie du
levier des ressources
parlons de la vraie diversité qui fera
en sorte que les gens vivront mieux sur
une vraie diversité
je pense que c'est aussi une clé sur
lequel il va falloir il me semble je ne
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
travailler avec objectivité avec les
bons mots si madame monsieur le ministre
alors sur la première question est en
effet je le redirai dans l'hémicycle
madame la sénatrice évidemment que le
culte catholique est considéré comme
étant quels que soient ces associations
diocésaines étant bien sûr une seconde
dite 1905 et que toute disposition
notamment positive parce qu'il y en a
pour les cultes non ce texte s'applique
à elle bien sûr et j'aurai l'occasion de
le redire je les écris d'ailleurs à
monsieur le président de la conférence
des évêques de france et c'est
d'habitude bien évidemment je constate
d'ailleurs que des dispositions dites
démocratiques délation 1905 ne
s'implique pas en tant que tel c'est
d'ailleurs en partie pour ça que
l'église avait refusé en 1905
application puisque évidemment la
solution étant diocésaine la paroisse
n'existe pas juridiquement et il n'y a
pas de bureau qui élisent des mecs
puisque je savais qu'il est désigné par
par sommes donc certains partis pour ça
que mes en partie pour ça que l'église
n'avait pas appliqué 205 avait demandé
quelque chose à part donc bien sûr se
sont reconnus sont reconnues comme tel
comme 1905 et n'ont pas besoin de faire
de changements de quelque sorte que ce
soit pour pouvoir rentrer dans les
règles édictées hier et aujourd'hui par
la république je redirai dans
l'hémicycle bien évidemment et je suis
très heureux de leur préciser madame la
sénatrice
vous avez mille fois raison moi je ne
dis pas qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre
immigration et séparatisme je dis que ce
lien n'est pas égal mais bien sûr qu'une
partie d'immigration non contrôlée de
gens non intégrés mène au séparatisme
bien sûr que l'urbanisme la politique du
logement
je dis pas qu'à un lien égal mais
évidemment contribuer au séparatisme et
bernard hoegy que vous citiez très
justement dans les territoires conquis
de l'islamisme et dans ses ouvrages
précédents évoqué non seulement
l'écosystème mais le fait que partout à
force de concentrer et de n'avoir que
des valeurs des remarques des marques
qui était religieux il recense religieux
islamistes on se séparait du culte pour
aller dans la société et que notre
travail à nous c'est de casser au moins
pendant des moments de neutralité
l'espace public par les services publics
la collectivité locale l'état
l'entreprise bon voilà on pourrait
parler unis membres des dispositions du
code du travail mais elle savait tous
que les les entreprises d'aujourd'hui
peuvent imposer des principes de
neutralité notamment par le règlement
intérieur et leurs représentants
syndicaux et notre notre travail à nous
républicain c'est à dire bien sûr vous
gardez est votre religion et vos
origines si vous le souhaitez mais vous
rentrez dans une communauté nationale et
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des moments de
votre journée des des repères qu'il
n'est pas qu'ils ne soient que des
repères religieux évidemment mais je
vous ferai remarquer que c'est facile à
dire et c'est pas facile à faire
notamment lorsque vous êtes en
responsabilité dans une collectivité
locale
d'abord la loi elle a donné le pouvoir
c'est el alami je pense que c'était une
grand drame pour la république que la
loi là me fait le carénage de la dsu ce
qui a beaucoup handicapé et a forcé
parfois les maires à garder des poches
de non mixité pour toucher plus de
subventions publiques
et ça c'est une erreur mais fondamentale
est le deuxième point c'est qui n'a
rendu est la donnée à l'agglomération le
pouvoir du peuplement ça peut
fonctionner parce que à l'échelle d'une
agglomération des projets en revue les
projets de repeuplement permettent le
rééquilibre dans une agglomération c'est
tout ce qu'elle est il plus pauvres il
plus riche encore faut-il que les villes
plus riches acceptent de mixité sociale
parce que moi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
constater dans les quartiers de
tourcoing et grâce à éclipse deux
gouvernements successifs nous avons pu
avoir un os rue extrêmement généreux que
les gens voulaient souvent restés dans
leur quartier même leur quartier que
l'on peut considérer comme divisible
certains s'en vont mais beaucoup veulent
rester et qu'on doit leur offrir une
mixité sociale et faire venir la
propriété dans un logement à la quartier
de la bourgogne à tourcoing c'est 92 %
de logements sociaux 92% selon sociaux
comme une commune de 10000 habitants la
bourgogne avec leur est quasiment des
logements sociaux de
faire accepter l'idée d'avoir de la
propriété c'est pas facile de servir la
propriété bien sûr dans ces quartiers
mais par ailleurs il faut accepter que
dans toute nouvelle construction y
compris le centre ville y compris dans
les quartiers plus plus classe moyenne
horaire ça comme ça voire même plus
bourgeois la mixité sociale et pour qui
est la mixité sociale pour qu'une bonne
politique de peuplement fois ça
équilibre est la population et on sait
tous que aller expliquer qu'on va
implanter désormais dans chaque permis
de construire 25 % de logements sociaux
la serbie et le sait nous le faisons à
tourcoing c'est la face il doit
expliquer à la population
et c'est encore moins facile d'expliquer
que les gens de roubaix bahizire on a à
bondues à mouvaux marcq en baroeul et
pourtant c'est ce qu'il faudrait en
partie faire pour mixer la population
donc il faut sans doute un travail très
fort sur l'immigration sans aucun doute
mais je crois que ceux qui mettent à
signer galles ne voit pas que le
problème est plus large que ça et il
faut sans doute avoir une action très
forte pour la mixité sociale mais ce
n'est pas dans le sénat que je veux dire
qu'il faudrait augmenter le pourcentage
de loi sru j'ai passé au je pense que
j'aurai un succès d'estimé
oui je pense que par ailleurs on voit
bien qu'il ya une difficulté d'appliquer
non seulement la rénovation urbaine au
niveau d'une métropole
quand bien même les élus seraient très
volontaires mais surtout de l'accueil de
la politique de peuplement des personnes
que vous déménagez de leur quartier et
je sais pas où construire madame en tout
cas comment obliger de faire construire
des logements notamment sociaux mais pas
que dans les quartiers qui n'ont pas ou
qui en ont peu parce que pour la bonne
et simple raison qu'on peut comprendre
qu'il n'ait pas envie de changer
eux-mêmes leur équilibre et leur
écosystème
si vous permettez cette expression donc
il faut un très gros travail sans doute
vous avez raison mais qui ne peut pas
tenir lieu de ce texte qui n'était qu'un
texte de police administrative mais qui
n'est pas un terroriste mais vous avez
bien raison merci madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre merci de ces deux
heures vingt de débats devant la
commission des lois ce soir et nous
suspendons la commission jusqu'au
l'arrêt jusqu'à l'arrivée du garde des
sceaux quart
merci